[Music]
welcome everybody it's h3 after dark
it's friday baby yeah
welcome welcome
is crazy poppin dude thank you you look
hella good thank you and you got your
hair done recently
i got it blow dried oh blow dryer but it
looks nice like it looks really nice
thank you and your nails you got the
hello kitty nails and once again pass
excuse me papa john i'm talking to my
lady
um
theodore picked out your nails picked
them up once again
he's already got good taste it's hello
kitty you guys can see it on her
instagram but i was like oh [ __ ] are you
popping over here bro wow
wow man yeah you look amazing i love
that jacket on you look at yourself with
the inferno
bear
yeah thank you i put gel in my hair this
morning
i don't usually i don't like care about
my appearance but on friday because i
know you're gonna be here i put gel in
my hair oh my god shaving on the
neckline i try to look nice
i try to look good for you i noticed you
did yeah i put it for you
you know
the package is still there
[Music]
check out this shirt that ela made
teddyfresh.com it's a bear on the attack
it's all teddy but who else got teddy
fresh on almost ever
got teddy fresh on
uh a b always a b is
true blue teddy fresh that sure looks
good too sam's also wearing this jacket
i know everyone every all the ladies are
wearing
isn't it the best it's like my favorite
right now
it's off at the or when it cuts off or
yeah like it's it's a little crop yeah i
love it nice
i gotta say i compliment abe because
he's like
fit you know he looks
i'm sorry i'm not to dismiss people but
abe always wearing teddy fresh and he
looks good in it so i love when ted when
when a bee wears it thank you thank you
for it you rock happy you're weird
you never wear it what am i oh the
beanie i mean what are you wearing a
beanie i mean what do you want
you got to be head to toe if you want my
accolades
oh wow
and it's storming out
dan is storming out in disgrace
i really liked it before when i had to
pay for it but now you know before i
worked here but now that it's free it's
even nice awesome yeah i love it
yeah that's the perk of working here for
sure come back then stormed out to get a
lacroix
daddy fresh no
oh no who else got teddy fresh i'm gonna
give you a shout out let's play that
disco music i've got it i guess that's
him i can't tell it just looks black oh
yeah this is the velour one oh a little
darker down there you look too dark but
yo you had glasses on maybe or even when
the show started i thought you looked
really good yeah i was gonna ask you
about that what were those glasses i
thought you looked great in them dude
you look great
for um
a blue blocking light because i had a
headache oh oh oh so you don't need
specs you just you're just walking the
blue i got that lasik a few years ago
right right right right oh yeah how
funny because i i just saw you in the
glass and i thought you looked really
nice thank you it's very kind of you
thank you
and please stand up zach
the uh the legendary zach how are you
doing my golden boy that's number the
sound bite god forever and always baby
[Music]
zach's gonna work let's see zach's nails
yeah exactly let's see what your nails
rocking
little green and black joker brains
speaking of a handsome devil
we've got
white claw gay
is he making oh is he muted
uh you know he's not muted but uh go
ahead gabe but we can't hear you want to
say something oh
yeah oh here we go of course
golf course oh you're a golf game
just chilling in the golf course
watching people smoking
are you do you golf yourself uh
gabe
just i just had my second up
vaccine shot oh okay oh congratulations
are you feeling like uh do you feel
metal objects sticking to you or
anything weird
not today i'm okay
okay good i'm happy well it is friday so
um
is there anything you want to say about
it being friday or can you curse on the
golf
course i don't know
just gonna be discreet it's quiet i
gotta be quiet
you know
friday start of a four-day labor day
weekend right
now
it's a four-day weekend who's how is it
a four-day weekend
wait hold on gabe always has all the
energy i guess he counts friday
friday is the weekend for him baby
oh so when you say four day weekend are
you including today
yes oh okay okay that much that's nice
palm desert baby
calm desert baby
it's interesting that gabe has more
respect for the golf course than the
movie theater
because he was really loud in the movie
theater
can we get a [ __ ] baby yeah i think
those people don't miss around [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] baby [ __ ] baby weekend no work
no school [ __ ] baby labor day baby come
on baby
[ __ ] baby
labor day brother baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
baby i love that four day weekend game
you know we love you i hope you hit a
hole in one out there okay bud
hopefully yeah would you be lucky baby i
wouldn't i am baby come on baby [ __ ]
yeah
have a great weekend
game baby
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right take care buddy have a great
weekend all right
all right take care
four day weekend for gabe
yeah i mean every week is kind of a
seven day weekend for gabe right his
whole life is the weekend
okay i have to address something um
today's episode is sponsored by noom
thank you noom i wanted today i do have
a great service but we'll get to that
later yeah thank you um
a lot of people are asking for a gender
reveal
and no my nails are not agenda reveal if
that's what you were wondering nice try
it's just me
manifesting
uh
it's gonna happen in two weeks so
we have the big appointment yeah
where they're gonna say if our baby is a
boy or girl i think it's a girl
well
i'm manifesting your manifest thing
you know
all right so because thank you gabe for
the segway because it's labor day on
monday we're actually all going to be
taking the day off
a novel idea here at the h3 dedicated to
well gabe
yeah daddy and gabe's honor
well kind of because we're just moving
we're just going to move h3tv from
monday to tuesday so it's still going to
be the same amount of show
we just got a little extra week yes a
little longer weekend but there you have
it all right so tuesday we will be live
h3 tv thank you thank you peace and love
peace and love
i also want to say at the top of the
show here once again i don't think i
give enough love to our
loyal members our foot soldiers our
favorite troopers who subs who uh i
don't know do you call it subscribing
you call it
membering
sponsoring it used to be sponsoring and
then they changed it to member
the people who are are
members who get membership early without
ads and discord yadda yadda we love you
guys you make it all possible
that's it i said i love it
all right there's some debates breaking
out in the community
first of all a.b
told this harrowing story of how he
saved a child from burning cars did you
see that
okay
well
we were doubting the authenticity of his
story
he said he showed a video
of a car pulled over on the on the
freeway it was on fire and all the video
showed was him running away from the car
and we're like okay well
nice story was james charles in the car
or not
so never know so somebody actually left
the post on the subreddit um exposing ab
so i wanted to
i wanted to uh share this with you guys
i have i used to work in the auto body
shop with ab when we were in high school
are you scared
remember who this is you know who this
is um
i don't recall i have to confess that a
b and i actually made modifications to a
car said it would go on on to light on
fire on the freeway 10 years later at
the exact location that abe would be
would be at so he could save a family
thank you to the 27 year old baby abe
rescued for giving me enough courage to
speak
i knew it
knew it i knew it all along i never
[ __ ] believed
we knew it he planned it for clout this
guy said what we all thought he was
saying what we all thought
they forgot to mention the flux
capacitor
oh sorry i was hearing my own voice are
you time traveled yeah we time traveled
actually that's what we were building
the auto shop oh [ __ ] yeah
this is me doc brown and james charles
did you time travel i bet there's like a
there's like a back to the future where
abe just tries to get this job
like he's gone to like infinite
timelines yeah until the one where i
hire him
yeah
i would
for the record i still believe a.b no
matter what uh the post says wait you
you do believe him yeah i do believe in
you you believe that very controversial
yeah we sucker born every minute
there's been some great fan art too that
i actually think is worth
shouting out here
we talked about how dr phil doesn't look
like anybody
like he looks like nobody
and he's kind of like an alien-esque
dome so
we love that on the subreddit that's
awesome yeah
yeah it's
a doctor feel like an alien without
what's the number two photo oh right
right thank you i forgot i was looking
for this one
yeah he did you so dr phil posted this
on instagram oh my god he posted that
photo what
ugly you are disgusting i'm gonna kill
you
and i don't know yeah
s-i-m-p
okay this we have a lot of the top of
the show bent elect you guys remember
was the guy who makes the [ __ ] post on
tick tock everyone was clowning on with
like demonic copy pasta this
[ __ ]
he don't know [ __ ] because he came out
against you
like that's a death sentence bro
eat the [ __ ] out yep of all why also
what did you say about bentley i thought
i was the one slamming him i don't even
remember why did he single you out of
all people
here here's what bent elect said about
ela
top five five people who hate me number
one gila klein she looks like she hasn't
smiled in years so i'm not surprised
number two
like on a real like on a real note it
seems that people like to go after
first of all it seems like he's trying
to attack me through you that's like the
rice gum thing
right
but it's always like oh she doesn't
smile or oh she looks
like what do you think about that insult
because it's something i've i've dealt
with my whole life
so it's nothing new to me but i just
want to say
i don't fake laugh so
yeah i'm laughing because you big mad
that means you're genuine and he's a
fake ass
um
yeah listen sometimes i don't feel like
smiling he doesn't smile for your
benefit [ __ ] it's definitely a thing
with guys wanting women to smile they
expect it yeah like play your part yeah
be the nice toy that smiles for men
right
it's so it is so like
[ __ ] old-school misogyny
smile sweetheart
like when does a guy ever say about a
wonder does anyone ever say that about a
guy like it doesn't look like he smiled
in years oh my god no right never
i never heard that because smiling's
beta right smiling's made as [ __ ] yeah
being unhappy is alpha yeah yeah yeah
hating yourself
laughter is beta it's manly as [ __ ]
sorry you had to go through that eli
[Laughter]
i'm curious to keep going but you were
number one you got the spot of honor but
you know just because i said i've been
dealing with it my whole life i did
learn to be just more comfortable with
myself and i think a big part of it is
obviously you thank you and also
just like the our youtube channel and
our community and just like how i've
slowly
like they they accept me as i am
so i've learned to be comfortable with
myself like that and it's like yeah
that's just what i'm like so i just want
to say that
i guess that's a thank you to everyone
yeah this the community has been so nice
and supportive lately i mean it's just
so nice i i feel very appreciative to
the foot soldiers lately yeah the
community is very vibrant like the
subreddit and everything it's just
really it's really like a nice time
right
for the best part yeah
for the most part
yeah i mean i've been through work yeah
like
you're getting [ __ ] no i'm not getting
[ __ ] no i'm good i don't read the
comments maybe it's because i don't read
a lot of comments i'm good what do you
see
oh this is it on the discord
the discard gets a little wild i like
the twilight movies i mean there's
always a little bit of this and that you
like the most part it's good i do like
twilight
how do you know
you just said i like twilight
oh yeah that's right
[Laughter]
yeah but you know ela i think it's
really interesting because
yeah it's okay to be like introverted
and and um
it's not even like shy it's just you're
more you're by nature more reserved you
don't have any obligation to be outgoing
for people other people's benefit
right i think i was um yeah i was fired
from one job from for not being like
that was it when we were together it was
a waiting job yeah yeah because you
didn't was that the one where they fired
you for not putting on the makeup no
it's a different one oh my god
don't have enough uh
pepper in your horse you were a great
waitress
i thought
yeah
yeah
or straight up
when you're 20 like people you don't
know what's legal illegal you just kind
of oh labor laws in israel like
[ __ ] you like you're lucky if i pay you
you know
i think this guy was just trying to bait
a response and going after ela
i don't think he's that smart and he's
not that strategic
let's see what the rest of his video is
like got him back so fair is fair number
three some youtuber who said i found a
guy i don't like him he gives me the epg
dude stop it it's not funny it's not
stop laughing
yes
it gives me the heebie jack
number four the queen billy eilish she
roasted me back in october and i still
get heat from it and number five master
bucks some youtube guy i don't know much
about him but he was a part of the scary
trend so i appreciate it
say what
like literally all those other people
were like incoherently shouted out
all right we're in your walls ben
benny boy
look in your wall
all right now there was a heated debate
eel and i want you to weigh in on this
yes okay last episode
i was called out by the crew for leaving
fruit out
and what they s what they're supporting
evidence was one the one thing of fruit
like this yeah that wasn't rotten
that was fresh looking and didn't have
bugs on it
and you left it out for like overnight
overnight okay
now
everybody's been posting on the
subreddit being like oh ethan you're
attracting
flies yeah go ahead i saw that and i was
like what's happening on the subreddit
it's all about ethan leaving attracting
flies and [ __ ] so okay i
okay listen i don't yes in combination
with fruit and dog poop down
what is your take okay so but what's
happening that because i hear you guys
saying there are flies here
we have we had more regular fry of flies
not fries we had fries too but and now
we have a lot of fruit flies and nets
so when i got here i've been sitting in
the common area there for like 30
minutes
i didn't see one flying thank you
there's no freaking flies olivia what do
you think
[Music]
i think there are flies but where aren't
there flies okay where are the floods
okay so over there where we all sit
that's where i see most of the flies
really yes which
to be fair to ethan that's not where he
leaves his fruit but i do think the
fruit contributes a little bit at least
let me ask you this
that image up put the image up i just
sent in the in the whatsapp group okay i
sit there
here's one thing we didn't talk about i
sit by that table are you really gonna
try okay i'll put that on the screen
that's nothing i was sitting on the
table
okay
[Music]
the garbage can was full the stink was
so bad i couldn't even sit next to it
that was like three days ago
this garbage can was full okay now this
this i understand some of that food on
the top is some stuff i just threw in
there but like this is this is halfway
full and i've seen it full all the way
where the sink was so bad that i had to
move seats away from it olivia have you
experienced that
it once smelled so bad i had to take it
out
because it was so full and it smelled up
but that was weeks ago before we got
nats
because we used to have huge flies that
are now gone
well you have this trash can open this
this is a littered trash doesn't matter
we're talking about scent attracting fly
do you want to read you're talking about
scent if you want to maybe read this but
if you're when i got here and i was
saying i don't see any flies i heard
some of you guys saying it's here we're
in the control room weird everywhere in
your control it's literally everything
all right you made me do this ethan
show it oh god you made me do this
do you see any flies around my fruit
i don't think it's just like oh i put
this fruit here and flies can only exist
right where the fruit they would be they
would be attracted to the fruit and but
you think if you're talking about odors
that trash can is so putrid you can't
even sit next to it bro can you open it
doesn't matter that there's a lid what
do you want me to do in the discord open
the video i sent
you want me to open a video that's going
to destroy me i'm not going to edit it i
remember what i said you're asking me to
dig my own grave
discord's not open so hold on a sec
you know
i mean come on you guys
let's be fair here
if you're talking about scent attracting
animals
you could start with this stinky ass can
alright what is this you gotta drive
the top okay here it is
so this is after we recorded on the day
where we had the debate about the flies
okay go ahead there's some little gnats
right there
that just hopped out of the doggy bowls
another factor that i forgot to
yeah we didn't even bring up the dog
food that's left out for like weeks at a
time okay that i accept
that i accept that is in the control
room that i accept more than the the
it's because i'm leaving ethan alone
here you guys don't understand i do need
care anything is defense it's not what's
without his care
i do feel that it's unknown it's it's
not good
but if that's my point you see flies you
i never see flies on the fruit i'll
leave it here the whole episode you
won't see one plot
to also back up abu's point you know to
be funny i got no support
no support i love shredder and alfredo i
do but i've stepped in the show multiple
times
you did multiple times
and zach's like a dog like he doesn't
see what's down there so he'll be
walking for about 30 steps before he
realizes how many times do we get poop
inside what's going on here almost every
day that they're here
no not every day you the it was a
delivery guy he stepped in [ __ ] but i
actually [ __ ] oh my god i stepped in
[ __ ] and tracked it all over him ethan's
defense he's always the first one to
clean it he doesn't yeah of course he
cleans it when he sees it but they they
poop over in the corner nobody sees it
for hours come up with a schedule where
someone walks them if you're recording
for like a few hours yeah that's a good
idea and also you know this is just
funny i'm not even alfredo pissed on my
computer bag one time yeah
i'm sorry no no no i'm not mad at it i'm
not mad at it at all zach would never be
mad at you yeah
oh my god he invites just pee on him all
the time but i feel like guys
i understand listen okay let me read
this as a pest control technique i can
tell you blah blah blah you're
attracting flies with fruit and dog poop
okay the dog poop i'll give you
some tips i can recommend obviously
remove or cover fruit once done
obviously don't leave dog poop on the
ground i mean that's obvious
[Laughter]
dude does he i'm curious i think that
it's so awful here now it's not
there's like
eyes and poop everywhere
no it's a very i feel like dan is very
sensitive to flight like he's walking
around with like a bug assault
i just i went on a spree this morning
that's probably part of why you're not
seeing it i i i killed many flies
silent i respect your opinion what do
you think well i was trying to eat
oatmeal earlier today literally where
i'm sitting right now and i had to move
because nats kept coming and trying to
get in my oatmeal is it possible from
the kitchen you know what i'm saying
well they they get attracted by the open
fruit and the poop and then they lay
eggs in the drain this guy explains it
all this is a pest control guy he knows
about wait the food was left one time no
no no no ela they have one photo
we took a photo because we decided to
confront this is an ongoing hold on
outside this huge building there's fruit
there's flies all in the world right
they're flying around they're flying
around and then people don't understand
how big this building and then they're
outside a closed building and they go
oh ethan left ethan left the tupperware
fruit
let's all invade instead of by the way
the garbage can that olivia has admitted
stunk so [ __ ] bad which is closed
even when it was closed that she had to
literally move i that happened to me as
well let me spell this
hmm it doesn't make it's it the smell is
if you leave it open i agree i
contribute
but like it does but like how much does
this having to move because something
smells so bad
i can't smell the fruit
i sent a link of the very first episode
of off the rails in this office are you
serious this is what happens
i'm not here yeah you get that check at
the time stamp um ethan tell me what you
see
all right we'll
we'll talk about this
what am i gonna get yelled at from you
now how many people are going to grill
me on this one
ethan just a few days ago that he needs
an assistant
um yeah someone just falls
he doesn't care
and
[Laughter]
what the hell
people are so wild okay you found a fly
great job
any guys coming home with like bites on
you and stuff you know these flies you
know it's a very beautiful office
we just this sometimes some poops do you
have that picture that um
after i think it was a few days ago that
cam sent
cam sends a lot of pictures which what
are you talking about the one after a b
cleaned up
oh
i'll try and find it
dan's on the case all right come on you
guys
enough
i can't believe you're doubling down on
this i think you got roasted so hard in
the comments
i acknowledge but i'm just saying like
you guys
have are next to the kitchen and a trash
can that stinks so bad people have to
move seats you don't think that's
contributing to flying well it
definitely is not before it used to be
an open trash can but it it was changed
to one with the lead the stink is when
the lid was closed
i'm talking about a closed lid stink
here
it's hard for you to arg to make an
argument
when there is poop apparently in the
office and uh the fruit i thought this
happened one day
it may have happened more than once
but again like okay but like i'll put
leave this out you won't i'll show there
will be no fights
they do
no i agree but i'm just saying like here
you guys tell me if there's a fly during
the course of the show if you see a fly
attracted to this fruit all right you
tell me
and then people can see for themselves
that this is
fly repellent fruit this is special
fruit
genetically modified
all right enough
well what do the comments say are they
they're saying that you're with peace
and love you're wrong
they're saying ethan take accountability
i take accountability i gotta ship with
the fruit
but i'm just saying
the trash stinks guys ethan have you
never heard of fruit flies for
god's sake
just watch the fruit people keep your
eye on the fruit eh
they're definitely gonna come yeah okay
before we started the episode they were
all causing my eyes for some reason i
just wanted to fly out of my face well
there's something going on over there
someone need to wipe their ass over
there or something
all right here let's watch the fruit
we got something we got a beautiful
thing to keep our our eyes on as we go
all right
guys yes
moving on to my new favorite video
this is the best thing i've seen is
since the
sonic guy uh crashes into a window and
spills everything the whole order
so right here it is i don't know what
the [ __ ] this is but it's terrifying and
hilarious
there we go need sound yeah
[Music]
i've never seen
anything like it in my whole life oh my
god the way it is
is the best thing i've ever seen
apparently this is for a therapy
chiropractor it's gone wrong
yeah it's for chiropractic that's why
they have to launch your ass into the
air like a
what do you think rag that
that can't be good
no you don't say
well chiropractors convinced the world
that somehow bodies wwf cracking their
back is uh good for them bones so
you can convince people of anything
it's awesome anyway um i made a button
so that now at any point i click this
button
and we can enjoy the video
so there you go
thank you thank you
did we add that sound effect that was in
the real video it was music from from
doom
oh
no that's the music that was in the
original it was just slowed down a
little bit yeah
let's try it again
bro that guy
that [ __ ] is so crazy man that's what
ethan's gonna do to us so we keep the
fly yeah you better you better
back there
uh no flies by the way the controller
will be above us
like everyone is like
i'll have you all hooked up at all times
and i've got a button suspended
[Laughter]
oh i got a meme here from cameron
lord of the flies
how dare you cameron
i am not lord
anyway we've got so much good stuff here
okay so now we come to a really special
time here um
there's one other meme oh this is sorry
this is so important you guys know owen
wilson the first time for me in the
marvel universe go ahead play it zach
this is the first time for me in the
marvel universe so he was promoting
loki right and they cut up his audio so
badly by the way loki was so good
yeah which now that i know that is even
crazier to think that they couldn't have
re-shot that well apparently the
marketing department because like they
put so much effort into the show
what i'm assuming is they just
had one brief interview
yeah but like
and he left he's like i can't come back
to that [ __ ] the marvel universe so any
but they did it again
for their new movie what's it called
so they did it again you guys wow hi my
name is aquafina and i am in the movie
wait is this a meme now
this is real this is real but are they
no this was another problem i don't
think so
i don't think so are they referencing
their i don't think so dude i just don't
believe in wasting a second
[Laughter]
like you could tell how edited it is
like first of all that's the cut and
then this she's not even talking
that's just b-roll
in the
it only gets bad towards the end it's
just that i am and
[Laughter]
the movie
awesome
all right we have a special uh segment
planned today yeah should probably do
the break first oh you want to do the
break while we get set up we're at 35
isn't there supposed to be a document
here dan yeah i'll i'll drop it in but
but we're at 33 minutes right so let me
do our sponsor and then we have a top
secret
special
segment
that did something you go undercover
don't know about love i'm deep
undercover a b doesn't know about it
you think you do but you don't
and we have something for
uh
zachary
and we have something
for uh
lovebot
because it's all their anniversary
surprises for everybody
and a b thought he was slick last night
and was like oh we got something for
love i was like
and we've got something for you that's
not all
okay so let's thank our sponsor then
we'll do our surprises and they're very
good
oh noom noom noo i'm
[Laughter]
every day
sponsor is noom
noom is a digital health platform that
helps empower you to take control of
your health eight eight eight noom
focuses on building healthy routines and
habits because there's so much more to
being healthy than just losing weight
and dieting okay okay
philly d once said i've lost weight and
i'm feeling better
i don't feel sluggish or unmotivated
which has helped me not spiral
and make the not best decisions from why
am i quoting
what i love about oh my i'm supposed to
and okay
i love noom it's helped me a lot can't
you tell
you did actually try it
once kind of a while ago and it did help
you
i used noon before yeah and i will say
it's awesome
it's really interesting program like
they put you in touch with a support
group through the app and like a ants
and uh
you get like a motivational uh
leader to keep you on track
and what's so cool is that you it keeps
track of all your calories
and as you eat certain types of foods
and you put it in it tells you
okay well this food is this healthy
or these calories are
like there's like red foods yellow foods
and green foods based on how much it
fills you up versus how many calories
you consume right so it's not only
counting calories it's also like
learning
what foods are gonna set you back big
time and what foods are gonna get you
the best
fill factor for your calories
very very very uh great
app that it's like educational too big
time educational yeah i used it for a
month and it was great for that month
but i think i just
i think my phone broke to be honest
and it's like such a fantastic
everything back on the phone i highly
recommend it though i should probably
get back on it newm connection with a
coach who's a real train oh they're
trained psychology fitness and tr
nutritional as well as other like-minded
peers to help guide and cheer you on as
you go
one of the best parts about neum is how
they couple their food and exercise
trackers with lessons and psych tricks
which are going to help you reach your
goal
they say do include an app demo overlay
dan
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
just use your imagination
uh listen if you're like me and want to
build out the habits and take control of
your health you can get a free noom
evaluation in a seven day trial when you
use mylakenoom.com
slash after dark please actually do use
that link because they're definitely
gonna be pissed about this ad read
but if the traffic is good they probably
won't ask questions
once again click the link in the
description or go to newm.com you'll get
a free evaluation and seven day trial
i really do love gnome
[Music]
nailed it
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right who who uh
all right let's do our um
you want to drop that anniversary uh
yeah thank you
up first who should we go first let's
see
okay we've got um
no let's start first of all zach has
been here for three years three years
wow three
years thank you thank you zach stand up
stand up zach stand the f up stand up
[Applause]
please stand up
shredder's clapping hi shredder
you want to tell me about your time here
i mean three years was a long time wow
three years uh
so i started out um before i was you
know this was a full-time job i was a
student i was um
out of audio engineering school and i
was in a pre-law program
and i was working here and
um
school wasn't
in the cards and i started working here
full-time and um
it's been uh
the honor of your life seriously though
i always tell people i have the best job
in the world like i said that cameo i
meant that thank you bro so
yeah i mean you really come into your
own over those three years man i mean
yeah we we've we've there's been a lot
of growth and a lot of accomplishments
thank you on your side and i'm couldn't
be prouder of you thank you thank you i
do appreciate that
um zach's um gifts we have
is this something that we have ready
okay so let's start there let's start
there
sam oh zach would you be so kind
we've been working we got to get a
close-up of this thing yeah we know
you're on keto and you're trying to lose
weight
[Laughter]
so what we've built for you is a keto
cake
wow now what is a keto cake oh my
goodness
[Laughter]
and
is that cooked on the bottom there that
looks like raw
it's all cooked i guarantee okay
oh it says three
yeah three years
so thank you so tell me about the
process i know sam and olivia you guys
cranked this thing out right olivia you
want to tell us about it
um yeah so i went over to sam and ian's
last night uh sam and i drank a little
wine had some cookies and then
we pulled out all of the raw meat that
sam so graciously picked up
let's do that cake this looks colossal
dude
it's four is it four layers
it's so there's three layers of ground
beef one layer
there's bacon all over the top and the
three and the meatballs are breakfast
sausages all of the cheese there's
cheese in between each layer of meat and
that would be wrapped
wow then
the nice thing is cheese whiz wow oh
jesus an entire cake
it's all keto there's no carbs in that
thing unbelievable thank you so much
let's crush that here i want to take a
bite i want to try it who's drying that
cake are we sure it's thoroughly cooked
yeah it doesn't the bacon looks a little
low
how long has it been in the fridge for
it's been in the fridge since last night
so the bacon yeah it's fresh
it just looks like it's not really like
crispy anymore you know
you guys cooked each part individually
yes yeah there's an album of uh oh yeah
you got it okay so this is all the meats
you can see
that went in
and this is how you make cake right like
look at the ground beef layers did you
guys season it or just oh yeah okay
good
oh man look at that that's the cake
and then dan you think you're going
breaking your vegetarian oh this is this
is pushing me to be vegan
[Music]
i'm so impressed it's like weaved oh
yeah
well thank you guys very much it's very
well bring it over here let's have a
bite i thought you guys were going to
say me and sam had some wine and we
ended up taking his [ __ ] on
yeah actually at the time that the
cheese was applied it really i was like
how did you guys i thought it was
scrambled eggs
it looks unreal it's a fat kid's wet
dream
well me and you are fat kids at heart
right oh
yeah that thing over here damn it let's
get some slices sam's bringing it over
oh by the way no flies
just so far no flies no fly and this is
here for all to see okay
thank you
i guess ethan and this is you breaking
the news that you're no longer vegan
oh well i think that he revealed down
the line
i'm pretty sure i broke that okay
i got arrested for it actually okay
sorry sorry i'm it takes me a minute to
catch up yeah
so that's love right there
sam we love you zach i love you guys too
thank you so as we is someone slicing
that up sam is yeah
okay so as we slice that up let's just
say a thank you
wait we this cake is only 2 400 calories
protein baby how's that possible
that's not possible
they say that cake is 2 400 calories
i don't believe it
that's a lot of calories yeah
bring it on baby that's like that's like
a month's worth of yeah
there's nothing i don't know i don't
know five big macs that's a lot bigger
and a lot more meat you know to
while they get that ready sam got
mcdonald's earlier and asked
for zach's order zach what did you order
from mcdonald's
so i'm not doing bread so i got sausage
egg and cheese mcmuffin but no bun with
an extra patty you seem to be skipping
them
not three of them what's the big deal
so which is how many patties it was six
patties thank you
bro i don't know man how are you how can
you lose weight and crush
they told sam they were like you gotta
wait we don't have that on hand right
now
they're like we gotta we gotta call hq
i was so [ __ ] hungry this morning
i absolutely want something yeah zach
never eats like that nice yeah let's see
the crosstalk this does not look good
i'm sorry
it actually looks like a cake wait you
guys really hold on look at this [ __ ]
this is unbelievable maybe you should
microwave it just yeah can we throw it
in the mic well hold on hold on hold on
you guys why the ground beef is a little
pink did we that's no it's a hamburger
so you guys got a nice medium low
yeah yeah yeah we did
you guys really went the medium rare
route on this i would not eat that ethan
you you can microwave it to be safe but
can we just acknowledge the
version
i mean this is incredible except like i
mean it's also disgusting but it looks
beautiful thank you sam's gonna
microwave let's i'll take a noob
[Laughter]
to be to be fair to the cake i don't
think eating that cold will do it any
justice
but so many people spamming do not eat
you're poisoning yourself
but the cross-sectional
[Laughter]
so um
next up we've got a b who's celebrating
his one year anniversary
a.b
how has it been for you one year
on the on the crew
life-changing i can't believe it's only
been a year
i can't believe it's been a year it
feels like wow
yeah crazy yeah
well i appreciate it feels so much
longer i'm so thankful for all you guys
and uh for the audience as well i
appreciate it you guys really changed
my life my wife's life
and it means the world
i still um
i remember how i was surprised that you
guys came here so fast like you were on
it oh yeah here in two weeks you can
offer me a job and he's like you could
come anytime within like the next six
months i'm like i'll be there in two
weeks okay
yeah well we offered and lino
also just been amazing life-changing
yeah you guys are great thank you thank
you life-changing for you though yeah
she loved you guys
the best
so i got you something special
fan of casey neistat
obviously
so i got a
message from casey for your
anniversary
not get too
excited i feel like this would be are
you excited i'm not excited not until i
see it tell me how you feel right now i
feel like it's gonna be [ __ ] dan with
some casey neistat no no it is
no it is casey neistat
[Laughter]
casey on cameo
no he's not this is a sp this is a
friend request
this is from one friend this is a
special favorite wow this is very cool
you think casey is on cameo
[Laughter]
happy birthday a.b
happy birthday
it's not his birthday
ethan and ela made me do this video
they wanted me to roast you
they told me to tell you to stop copying
my style
but congratulations on a one year
anniversary
congratulations
don't take it don't take too much [ __ ]
off ethan
[Laughter]
[Music]
i wanted to stand up and hug you but
thank you so much very sweet and thank
you casey that was awesome yeah thank
you casey yeah
i was like you i was like judas you
betrayed me
i wanted him to roast you don't check
but he was it was too sweet for all that
that's awesome thank you guys there you
go
oh okay
yeah we just did a nice thing for us you
got their roasted inside
it was a roast
[Laughter]
roasted meat in that case yeah
yeah casey's a great guy wow what a nice
guy you know i sent him i said yeah
bring that bring that in thank you
i said hey man
you know my
still a little pink but we love that
jesus
how long was this microwave before
i think it's a little cold in the middle
still
i can take off the top here
all right
yeah anyway i messaged casey i was like
yo you know a b
ooh
he's a big fan
i don't think that's going to help
anything
and he sent it immediately so he was on
it he was really sweet
that's awesome how does it how does it
feel knowing that he knows your you
exist but all the all the x's are
checked
you know in case you know my sim
dreams are all fulfilled
it's not bad
like the breakfast sausage yeah
i don't know about the cheese whiz to be
honest i don't like it
you like that
the bacon kind of concerns me though
here i'm gonna take a full bite of the
main cake body
dan's nightmare
you need a drink
you need a beverage
it's really good
i'm being honest
it's not bad
keto and [ __ ] keto dude
i think i needed more i'm sorry it's
really
it's just not right
you know what
i'm good thank you so much thank god
yeah i'm done too sam thank you
i do appreciate it
olivia ian it would be rude not to
even having the meat cake no flies
people are predicting a four-day area
weekend
that's become pretty commonplace for me
of course yep
if our office was infested with flies
not gonna belabor this but don't you
think you would see at least one
fly or not or something by now
you're right no no no you're actually
right we've just all of us collectively
have been having a delusion that we're
just constantly berated by flies all day
while we're here critical evidence dan
it's like the lord of the flies we're
getting delusional man
empirical evidence over emotion emotions
facts don't care about your emotions
damn that's true facts don't care about
my feelings
it's like if they're so attracted to
this fruit
you think they'd be like whoa
but now they're like oh we don't get we
only care about what's going on in dan's
desk
i would like to retract my statements
ethan is innocent it was dan all along
it was me [ __ ] on the floor all over
the place
you're gonna need to explain how we're
about to do a three-hour episode of no
[ __ ] fly there's literally a fly in
front of my screen right now i'm not
kidding it's just why is it there
they're just every it's ambient it's
everywhere
not here
how is it attracting flies and they're
not here oh
god next to him
get
my
i think dan is like a fly phobia
my dad is the same way i bought my dad
that first birthday the bug assault yeah
that thing's pretty cool i gotta say
it's fun have you gotten good at aiming
it takes some practice right crack shot
do you use the scope
of course yeah
proper trigger discipline the whole
thing
and and last but not least of course
we have love who also is celebrating his
one year anniversary that's hard to
believe i cannot believe it's been a
year long
yeah
how's the year been for you bud
um
out of this world completely crazy
i
[Laughter]
i was supposed to go back to school this
year
i had like this very shitty job pain
got paid from nothing doing nothing
and i really hated it and like all of a
sudden i got a dm from you guys
offering a position and
yeah from there on i've just literally
been happy every day
that's like the best thing ever
that's so awesome dude and you do great
work you're such a great
you're such a great uh addition to the
crew and
it's funny even though you're in sweden
because of the love bot
it actually i know it's kind of broken
right now we're working on a replacement
but
it really feels like you're in the
office since you got the bot
yeah
um but yeah thank you for the amazing
work happy one year and we got uh we got
you a present too out all the way out in
uh sweden you do you have it can you
show it
yeah i don't know how you guys managed
but i didn't open it yet actually oh you
didn't open it yet oh [ __ ] okay so open
it on screen okay let me get that out of
there
it's like a giant box and try not to dox
myself okay so we sent the package out
to love in sweden
so
oh there's a note here it's a no i don't
know
love thank you for being an amazing
member of our team we're thankful for
you
cheers beautiful
oh he's going in with his teeth
wow
impressive
it's a fika attack dude
attacking the ribbon with his teeth he's
opening it what's inside oh my goodness
oh my goodness
let's see it
it is a cake with
love squidward
love butt later
[Applause]
here's the image for you guys that can't
see
yeah show the cake let's see how they
did a comparison oh okay
that's awesome that looks great i don't
know how you guys managed to get get
this cake out to me
i live like out out in
nowhere make it happen we make miracles
out here nation
by the way this image is so interesting
how like there's
pores only here on his forehead
did they capture that detail love
yeah that's the only place i of course
okay interesting
well thank you all you guys
i really genuinely
i appreciate you guys so much the family
you know i was it struck me the other
day i was sitting in the kitchen and i
was thinking to myself
like these are the good times
in 20 years or 30 years or whatever
i'm gonna look back
and remember all you guys
and the show and the special thing we
have
these are the good times
we're in them now and then a fly hit
your face no flies there's no [ __ ]
flies anywhere near me there's gonna be
so many flies they're gonna hit you but
when i'm dead yeah
nope flies won't be attracted to my
corpse only they're only attracted to
dan
no but
okay cameron sent this
all right is this real
is that real that's 100 real
what was all the black [ __ ] man's flying
those are flies dude
that never happened
you're like immune to it you don't even
notice it's literally crawling all over
the lens of the camera take that off
take that off no
um people do say that they come to old
fruit
okay
why do they come to okay all right
i think i read that some
flies are already in fruit as well
but they need like
heat humid um
temperature to hatch
sorry to gross anybody out but i think i
read that recently any other theories on
where the uh
immaculately conceiving
but anyway as i was saying get bring
back the sentimental music please
that it's good to reflect like these are
the good times you
know and i just want to say that uh
you guys are the best
that's very sweet and the show wouldn't
be what it is without you guys so
well we appreciate you guys our lives
want to be what they are without you
guys so yeah thank you
thank you for the many years of hard
work that you guys put in before us so
that we could be here today peace and
love wait do you mean lives are you
talking about your instagram live
no i'm talking about eight straight
street productions okay
live
thank you ap i just i just want to say i
want to thank you guys
yeah go oh so i want to thank you ethan
and ela and i want to thank the audience
the foot soldiers and um
it's really just been the most amazing
thing and uh i'm very grateful what
about me i want to thank you zach for
[ __ ] up the moment when i was talking
so then you could have the mic jack you
kind of copied what av said a little bit
after interrupting i interpreted because
he's always i because he thanked the
audience and then but then you came back
and thinking well you got to thank the
audience you got it all so you thanked
ethan and ela you thank the audience i
hired you zach that is very true i met
dan at a coffee bean
yeah we had we went through like extra
for some reason precautions with zach
because it was a cold email well yeah
and we just want to make sure he wasn't
afraid
the treatment though we want to make
sure he wasn't a freak so you sent me to
meet him yeah
better you than me
i met dan at that coffee bean and uh we
struck up a conversation and he looked
at my resume and he's like oh you want
to come in and i'm like [ __ ] yeah i want
to come in and [ __ ] it
i was like bro that's thai
thing
i've learned so much from dan oh loves
eating his cake cake reveal
cake review am i supposed to eat this
whole thing myself
you do whatever you want with it man if
you could [ __ ] like toast intelligent by
the way
if you could ship me a slice
actually yeah that'd be cool
delicious awesome you can ship it back
to us we shout out sam for
finding someone to deliver a cake in the
middle of at a certain time
it was not easy so it was not easy yeah
i don't understand how you guys made
that happen miracles happen
every day here in this office i think
including the immaculate conception of
flies that don't exist
i think uh sam got a call actually she
stepped away but at like 2 a.m
sweden time and they were like we can't
ship a cake to the united states she's
like no no
all right
thank you thank you enough sucking each
other's dicks yeah and actually uh just
real quick um there's a super chat i'd
like to read from uh happy fat pilgrim
ten dollars uh they have a confession to
make
they are a nano technology engineer a b
had me design and manufacture miniature
robotic flies he currently has me
working on an ai ian hunter killer drone
that is a huge confession yeah
ab i got to say there's a lot coming out
in the last couple weeks like i know
it's your anniversary and everything and
i don't want to deflate this at all but
um that was actually not the real casey
neistat
what was that an ai
he was a paid actor oh my god you set
that up
yeah
all right let's move on
um this is a real post from gosar
you guys remember gosar he's the guy
that got his whole family ghost heart he
won
he did his whole thing yeah he's like a
total he's like one of the biggest [ __ ]
bags surprise surprise
in uh congress but
um
he
his whole family made a video his
brothers and sisters and everyone said
do not vote for my brother he's a piece
of [ __ ] he's still one
anyway he's posted this
he posted this on on
on twitter yeah he did
and uh i guess it's some meme about how
alpha he is because his sp he stands up
straight yes there's a whole there's a
whole alpha meme about how you lean in
it's like a red-pilled uh
men's uh pickup artist kind of thing so
if you lean in like this you're beta but
if you stand firm you're alpha that's
the theory
so gosar is alpha and he's calling out
the cactuses for having a beta stands
there
so he's meaning
that appears he is he he turned off
comments by the way on this boat
no replies
i'm not sure what that means but so we
decided to do our own
alpha posture
he turned off comments because it
backfired everyone said why you have an
arrow pointing to your dick
i noticed that when you pulled it up
just now wait let me pull that back up
better it's just pointing to his dick
yeah
yeah
kind of
i guess yeah
got some low hanging fruit that's what i
was gonna say this is where how low my
balls drew
old as [ __ ]
such a weirdo dude
anyway here's our line you guys we did a
well somebody on the subreddit first
pointed out
in one of our group photos oh okay
so wow actually interesting oh i passed
the alphaness that's awesome and lavabot
olivia dan fail ela i mean
i feel like you're pretty close to this
passing we could argue she's a sigma
yeah i think that's the sigma energy
yeah
love is obviously the most alpha
[Laughter]
and a b you're leaning like bro how
better does it get
leaning in like that at that angle
better for life i'm alpha as [ __ ] boy
yeah so where's our one from today do we
have it
oh uh
yeah
so we should we took a photo today
to assess our alphaness
and i think we all did pretty good
here it is
so
we all been working on our alpha stance
and unfortunately
everyone
but sam and a.b failed
you gotta work on that lean in navy it's
so beta bro
it's the tilt of the picture
look at ela though she's a killer alpha
super alpha
you see zach doesn't lean in he can't
lean in he's too big
he's too tall
what if he leans we're going to fall
like dominoes he can't lean
okay
i'm just too alpha for him all right
let's look we've got so much [ __ ] to do
here okay um
we've got a la bane test we talked about
last we have to get to joe rogan being a
giant ding-dong
i rage baited all the joe rogan uh fans
you see what the title of this episode
is called oh yeah joe rogan's a giant
hypocrite
i believe it i'm not giving that guy any
passes dude
you know
um here we got some great tick tocks you
want to watch
yeah this one is really good bro
really good
yo
wow
[Laughter]
is she more distraught about the farting
or the falling it's hard to tell
are you okay
and you know what then when i realized
her kids are there and they look so
concerned
i feel so bad for those sweet kids i
love them yeah
you shouldn't have to watch your mother
rip ass like that
she's shocked that's not real i think
it's the leather on her boots wait you
don't think the fart happened no i think
she squeezes the leather on her boots
when she falls but she looks so shocked
that like she passed gas
it looks like she broke her
she fell over
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
oh my god
[Music]
let's do some investigating it just
seems like a weird place to edit in a
fart
here let's do some investigating
reddit detectives always figure this
[ __ ] out
okay oh hold on one sec
[Laughter]
love him
okay
i don't know man i mean i understand
there's a lot of people saying boots
scrape on pavement too heels on concrete
yes it's the heels dragging
and the fart is fake
not a fart
it's the heels yeah i'm sorry that's not
a fart my dude
someone said oh her heel dragging okay
all right let me watch again with that
context of mine yeah you think it's the
heel dragging on the con people saying
it's the heel not a fake sound i mean i
see all of these i just thought it was
just
are you okay
yeah it's so loud it doesn't fit with
the rest of the context of the audio i
think it's just why would someone add a
fart there i think why not because it's
funny
it got you it doesn't make sense to add
a fart but it sounds so loud
can we get a slow motion well yeah and
then and then by the way they're not
they're talking very quiet okay so if
she's got a lot of demands for a poll
i'm gonna set one up well listen okay
if she's everyone's talking really
quietly so i mean if she falls with a
lot of force and her and her heel
scrapes hard that's gonna make a loud
sound
and now i hear the scraping i hear the
scraping now
it sounds more like
are you okay
i can't you don't hear it no i think you
know you sit on like a like a plastic
couch and it makes like that weird sound
i think it's the latex on our boots that
are like collapsing onto itself and then
making that like
sound so it's i think the sound is real
but it's not a fart
i feel like it's edited oh brother
so am i going to pull is it a fart yes
or no it's a sound effect or no it's her
boot scraping whoa
that doesn't make sense those choices
you said yes it's a fart
or it's a sound effect so you don't need
to yes no no it's shoe it's is it the
shoe yeah i'm giving an option or a
separate exactly that's not what you
said yes it is yes
one option one yes option two no it's a
sound effect
option three no it's her boot scraping
there's no such thing as the coins
there's no such thing as a coin
let's slow it down now before you guys
vote i just want to make sure everyone
makes the most informed decision
possible
no flies by the way not one fly
not one wait people do you have her tick
tock
because someone said
she literally has the fart queen in her
tick tock bio oh [ __ ] she does let's
find her tick tock then cause that's
actually really good evidence we have to
forensic we have to approach this at all
angle as possible yeah we're gonna touch
this
we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna first watch this
in slow motion
okay now everyone watch this
[Music]
okay
now she's about to slip
[Music]
now
you can see at this
no you can see where the sound could be
generated by her boot at this moment it
slides
cross-legged underneath her
right here
[Music]
so if that's a fart that's a clean fire
dude well yeah it would mean it would be
expelled from her body and with force
there wouldn't be any subtlety to a fart
like that certainly not
right
did we find our tick tock
someone said it's the fart queen which
would be damning evidence
let's be honest
[Music]
the votes are in
[Music]
oh well you guys don't okay okay this is
interesting put it on the right i can't
so you guys did
um
this is very interesting the results dan
can you put it on
it the website's going oh here we go i
finally went okay here we go so we have
it's her boots scraping
in the top
yep
and number two it's a sound effect the
yes is very low only fourteen percent
well
they're out there
there's still some that believe yep
yeah i actually do think it's the boot
scraping as well but if it
if she says spark queen that is like
okay
are you gonna be making this sound uh
ela
wait here's ela in the bathroom
wait here here's me in the bathroom
watch this here's me in the bathroom
i don't know what that means
jake goes down in the bathroom that's
what happens when i take a [ __ ] my body
just
repels and i go my body
launches to the ceiling oh my lord the
propulsion of a
of a nuclear thrust
it was my boot scraping i might have
been loud enough to be picked up on the
mic
you could definitely hear that yeah yeah
i heard that
i heard that from sweden
[Laughter]
um no i really heard it good morning my
queens of tick tock above 18.
charleston
you guys are gorgeous
get up get out of bed get that day going
send them videos we love them
take note james charles queens of
tick-tock above 18. can you sound bite
that zach just good morning queens of
tick tock above
he's right you gotta add that
do we have any coke zero anywhere ab
like next door maybe
oh i didn't see any
oh this is the best i want to wait i'm
waiting for you to see this this is
freaking crazy bro
you see
okay what is that good
dude
dude
do not go paragliding in or parasailing
in mexico
in fact don't do anything in mexico i'm
sorry
no we've been
we love mexico i do but like bro
look this is i mean like
okay let me see this is this kind of
[ __ ] that goes down
i'm sorry what's up storm's coming in
that's all rain out there and lightning
and this parasite are stuck it's so
windy they can't reel them
in dude if it snaps
look
dude he's got he's gotta be scared of
[ __ ]
see everybody panicking trying to help
[Music]
the line broke and this dude who's on
vacation is floating off into football
[Music]
that's what i'm saying you go on zip
lines down there you go sailing i mean
[ __ ] i don't know how well that stuff's
maintained
well i mean
i wouldn't go parasailing with a [ __ ]
hurricane bearing down yeah that seemed
like a bad idea yeah this seems like a
bad decision
dude
he's gotta be scared of [ __ ] i think i
feel like
well the reason we stopped going to
mexico is because of the [ __ ] cartel
[ __ ]
and the police shaking us down there
there's actually another part to that
video
oh my god there is
yeah
can you send it
i'll look for it
uh itself there's no coke zero
unfortunately
tragic
i read by the way that um
he the guy somehow was totally fine
really i was reading in the comments
that he like landed safely i don't know
how that's possible that is actually i
feel like i've had nightmares literally
of this happening
you just float off
do you accept death at that point like
what i wonder what was going through his
head i mean that's yeah
yeah i think you just accept that
because like
in mexico it's all like i would imagine
off the coast there
it's probably just like kind of jungly
and tree and tropical it's like
you're not going the chance you just go
into an empty field is very low i think
he got caught in a tree or something
he went over a city i think
you have the second part for me no i
can't find it i don't know
i'm trying to yeah that's pretty well i
wonder if it's on this guy's page
no i didn't find it there
[ __ ] hell
all right you want to do this labane
test ab
yeah let's do it okay so lavenae's this
cheat oh my god you bought all this
lebanese
you clean them out or what
oh you put it back
so this is lavenae it's lebanese
cheese that ela loves very popular in
israel too i i never got a taste for it
i think it tastes [ __ ] i actually hate
this [ __ ]
like ela was always all about it oh this
is good pita
by the way it was a woman not a guy oh
life yeah
oh according to this headline drifting
for 45 minutes oh oh we got tea yeah oh
well here let me just uh link you
to this
okay so apparently this woman when that
snaps went drifting for 45 freaking
minutes you guys
holy crap
yeah she didn't die though
i would think that was certain death i'm
not sure if this is the same wait this
is her
she broke her pelvis and four ribs
oh earlier this wait is that her
oh my god this poor woman is this the
same crash though it's in puerto
vallarta i don't think so and what did i
tell you
it's not the only parasailing accident
wait but this is actually from 2018 the
article this should just happen
how many how many other people getting
injured out there let me try this love
now i don't know
so yeah this is lebanon very popular uh
people eat it it's meant for breakfast
but people eat it all day
lena's family kind of survived off of it
really these the kids yeah they eat it
all the time lina loves lebanon she's
lena eats lebanon cereal
[ __ ] those are her two dishes yeah you
don't wear olive oil oh that was an and
not in it
like the one in israel was like why do
you guys say disgusting just say you
don't like it could i say it's my
favorite for anyone who wants to try it
too yeah you guys should all try it
yeah okay that's what it tastes like
it's just a little sour
not for me
thank you
i'm offending you
you're just getting into this about the
lemonade disgusting that's what i wish i
would go out to eat like i hate this
[ __ ]
there's a lot of like i don't like
lebanon that that yogurt drink oh you
know i don't eat that i love it
everyone should try this yogurt drink
too because it's pretty i brought if
people want to try it maybe just get a
little glass so we can pour
oh thank you ap you don't like this
even
good it seems
comparison
it seems mild it's not that's what it
tastes like because well to be honest
with you trying it now it tastes pretty
good okay i think your memory is a
little off then because that's what it
tastes like
great i like it it's like a sour cream
it tastes like sour cream a little sour
sour cream
sorry i heard someone gagging zach is
there a problem
no problem at all oh but you hate sour
cream let me ask you this what if ethan
said he liked it
he couldn't be like can like whatever i
don't ugh actually i love it
i'm sorry to drink this i can't remember
i think so um is it pasteurized it says
pasteurized milk and cream
it's awesome you don't like it baby
i'm not a fan of it yeah you guys got to
try that it's so it looks it's a yogurt
drink you would think oh yogurt drink in
america yogurt drinks are sweet
but in lebanon they're
salty as [ __ ] it's sort of like a mango
like i mean like a lassie like a if you
ever had like a
lassie bite it's a salty one yeah i
don't know we like salt we put salt and
lemon on our eggs i don't know if that's
not that sounds good it's not right
right
yeah it ain't right
that's one of the most disgusting things
already thank you
that's that's awesome this is
horrific finally somebody everyone it
tastes like everyone here hates it it
tastes like
sweden too it tastes like curdled milk
it tastes like the ocean
yeah okay i see that i can't even smell
it
that was horrific thank you people eat
this or drink this drink they drink it
and they'll have like cheese pies
they love
i had it in turkey for the first time oh
yeah i guess in turkey it's called the
sodium
i don't pronounce it but love brought it
up last time
why did you say love
a thousand well a gram a gram there's
almost a gram of [ __ ] sodium in this
oh god it's iron in turkish uh there's
no percent of your daily sodium yeah
that's what it's called yeah yeah low
carbs though
exactly how much to slam the whole
bottle yeah you drink mayo it's the
[ __ ] let's put the money on it let's
play
i know i'm a little bit of a drink this
dude just [ __ ] ate like half rob
bacon and in like four layers of ground
beef i did that
yeah but you're not going
i can't even smell it i'm good i'm that
you want to slam that zach
how much we pay him how much
500.
you better do it dude lebanese people
about to cancel you
antarctica lebanese people be like i
paid for that [ __ ]
500 i don't think i don't think that's
at the end i don't think i can and
dude i mean you know i don't know if you
would it may or not this male i maybe
cuz i'm just not used to it or that you
know the smell or the flavor i'm being
told to make sure to shake the bottle
before drinking it yeah of course i
shaved it dan got a lot of curds on the
top oh i didn't right
and you said it was dirty i wondered if
maybe you didn't shake it yeah you got
to shake it oh wait did ian try it
i do i think you don't like it that's
what i don't want to pay him
i'm not crazy about it but i didn't
shake it either so let me try again
i'll try it again it's gonna it doesn't
it's not gonna taste better i mean
this is very surreal right now
hey b i love you i don't want to offend
anybody i'm just messing with you
ila what do you think about this trend
there's a trend on tick tock it doesn't
help of people punching food and i know
it's meant to be funny but it actually
just upsets me like i don't like it i
think it's just like
very annoying i mean here
what
it's like a gag but i mean it's just
i mean
it's so aggressive this one's funnier
than the other ones
uh it's all flipped
here here's one of a dude punching
like a birthday cake you know and i just
don't approve of it
nacho cheese
[Music]
benny boy
man
those nachos are crunched as hell now
fat ela hasn't smiled since she was born
mike why mike start like an old car
starting
[Laughter]
here's the one that annoys me the most
here's a compilation
but i know it's like a joke in the group
but one dude takes it way too far
and you're like dude it's not funny bro
please stop you know
oh
nobody's really enjoying it no
no
i hate it
don't be that bad please i absolutely
hate it yeah don't be that guy okay
thank you
oh now we get to the joe rogan portion
of the show you guys ready
oh boy
[Music]
i've dreaded this day
but here we are
it's like joe rogan first of all he got
covered okay let's watch the video
but the guy
has been a [ __ ] up
in every way when it comes to covet he's
encouraged people not to wear masks
and not to get vaccinated
if you're healthy and have a strong
immune system like he apparently does
right and fauci had to correct him right
and yeah fauci's like please don't
listen to joe rogan
so um so like now when he got it even he
[ __ ] up but here let's watch his video
of him saying
hey y'all
caught myself some kovid
hello friends
so i got back from the road saturday
night
feeling very weary i had a headache and
i just felt just run down and just to be
cautious
i separated from my family slept in a
different part of the house
and throughout the night i got fevers
and sweats and i knew what was going on
so
i got up in the morning got tested
and turns out i got covered so we
immediately threw the kitchen sink out
all kinds of meds monoclonal antibodies
uh ivermectin that's what i don't get do
you really have that stuff at home by
the way of course not he went to a super
high-end doctor and paid a shitload of
money for the best treatment in the
world just through the except for the
horse pace which we'll get to you can
buy that uh
you can bet that buy that from petsmart
i believe
no actually tractor supply
although it was sold out when i did oh
for real tractor supply
yeah that's kind of director attractor
that's the name of the store
oh well we'll look at it i don't want it
it's a chain anyways okay yeah it's the
horse dewarmer
and it's sold out we've tried to buy
some for the show and [ __ ] around the
country have sold out tractor supply on
horse pace to deform those [ __ ]
yeah it was a few days ago let me see if
they've got rogue
squeezing the tube
[Applause]
ivermectin
but if this guy is such a oh they had to
put warnings all over the
oh this wasn't here the other day oh let
me see i want to show it
okay so here's the medicine i actually
have a warning fda has not approved
if i uh how do you say
for preventing or treating coven people
like like i give a [ __ ] it's sold out
bro oh this one actually is uh available
an injectable kind there's a horse on oh
you should have to inject that
well okay so we should we should clear
this up
there's a horse on the box people yeah
so ivermectin is
yeah yeah yeah i'll get it i'm gonna
i'll get it to it i don't wanna i don't
wanna go in too big yes it's approved
for humans right honestly not for covid
on on a specific dose yeah okay okay for
specific reasons right not treating
kovid but what people are buying because
they don't want to go to a [ __ ]
doctor
they're buying it from
or moreover their doctor won't prescribe
it to them they ask for it and their
doctor is like i'm not going to give you
that
that will only harm you
so then what they do is they're going to
like
tractor supply and buying
the dosage for a [ __ ] horse
horses are massive creatures thousands
of pounds yeah a little a little bit
and
people are getting super sick taking
horse dewormer
guess who took that [ __ ] bro rogan
but what i was gonna say is like he's
been talking about how if you've got a
healthy immune system you don't have to
worry you'll be fine it's like okay then
why don't you put your money where your
mouth is and why did you like go to a
specialized doctor and get like
experimental drugs and try every [ __ ]
thing
under the sun i just it's like bro
you're obviously just
he's obviously scared as he should be
it's not a good thing to get right he
was scared yeah because he's in his 50s
you know
his the first day he felt horrible yep
but i just that's why i don't get is
that
he's encouraging people not to get the
vaccine
who are healthy
yet when he got it
he freaked out
and got like all the highest level
treatment possible it's like
so you're going to go support the
vaccine now you're [ __ ] better
but the other thing that's really dumb
about this hero play what's going on so
i got up in the morning got tested
and turns out i got covered so we
immediately threw the kitchen sink out
all kinds of meds monoclonal antibodies
uh ivermectin
z pack
uh
prednisone
everything uh desperate [ __ ] now let me
break down the [ __ ] he took
because this is especially
frustrating now joe rogan took regeneron
which you guys may have remember is what
trump took that miraculously cured him
this is a first of all ironically a lot
of people are not taking the vaccine
because it's under emergency approval
it's not been properly tested guess what
else is under emergency approval and
hasn't been proper properly tested as
emergency use authorization regeneron
yeah regeneron
yeah it's highly experimental it's
highly experimental so what the [ __ ] bro
it's super upsetting because he he tells
his millions of listeners
that if you are in good health whatever
young you don't need the vaccine
but then he has access to this crazy
stuff that no one else does i don't even
know where you get it and then he got it
and he panicked and took everything that
he could you can buy a dose of it for
thirteen hundred dollars you know what's
free the vaccine
well actually the regeneron stuff is
also available for free from the
government um but it's extremely limited
um because it's really hard to produce
and moreover it's very hard to store
and so
it's very difficult to get it out so
they only use it in really extreme cases
or if you're joe or if you're joe rogan
exactly i mean
so he's basically helps to be a
billionaire or whatever it's easy to
preach [ __ ] that's going to get people
hurt and then when you [ __ ] catch the
disease that you've been downplaying you
run to
your super
privileged rich ass
because you were too much of a [ __ ]
or too much pandering to your psychotic
you know well i'm not gonna listen
there's lots of normal people that
listen to joe rogan but there's a lot of
people who listen to joe rogan now who
are vaccine hesitant and don't want to
hear joe daddy joe rogan got the shot
so you're either pandering to a portion
of your audience too cowardly to get the
vaccine because you don't trust it for
some [ __ ] reason
so you run to your
millions of dollars and get treatment
that wouldn't be accessible to the vast
majority of your audience now here's
what else pisses me off
so regeneron is a real drug
it is almost it's been described as like
a miracle drug it's the real deal like
that one
you know obviously barring the fact that
it
most people can't access it and it's a
little unfair that joe rogan can just
demand it and get it immediately but
yeah that that supposedly works on covid
like it's it's a good drug it probably
saved trump's life okay so regeneron
um is a real drug and it's experimental
it has emergency authorized
uh authorization from the fda just like
the
covet vaccines
and that is a real one but what else he
includes he says them like they're all
equal right
he says i took this this this so he took
that one what else he says is [ __ ]
horse paced he says i took this cutting
edge
uh
i took this cutting edge
incredibly researched and developed drug
that's basically a miracle drug
and i also took horse paste
and he puts them side by side and
there's a lot of people that are going
to listen to that and be like oh well it
was probably the horse pace
not the regeneron
and again because he has access to a
doctor that will likely give him a
prescription to whatever he wants he
probably got the real ivorman joe rogan
is not sucking down tubes of uh yeah
very unlike cattle level right but most
people can't get that and that's why
they're going and getting the horse
version or or there's a sheep version
too that people are
oh it's a
there's a bunch of i think maybe even
more than just those two cows too it's
like it's a bunch of agricultural it's
used in agriculture to
de-worm
here this comment also is interesting
because she's saying that it's i don't
know if it's that's the one but one of
them is used
in the veterinary
narrative field to treat heartwarm which
can be deadly in dogs and it's on back
order now and pets are suffering right
that's the other angle right is that now
it's sold out because morons like joe
rogan and now but this is the thing he's
he is encouraging people indirectly to
use this because it cured him not the
regeneron right and so there's animals
that actually [ __ ] need this medicine
now that are unable to get it because
[ __ ] are put are basically spreading
it on their toothpaste like [ __ ]
and some i've read some horse like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you up
the the the paste i'm sure i've read
some like real disgusting horror stories
about me
it it's like
give me the horse space scoop i guess it
[ __ ] with the lining of your intestines
really bad
and um people or
people are like literally [ __ ] out
their intestines it's like yeah it's
really bad what it's really meant to do
warm dogs and horses about to deworm
your friends
i read some really horrific horror
stories from because there's all these
groups on facebook that are encouraging
each other to do it and i've seen posts
where people are like hey guys i took it
and i'm a little worried uh there's like
this long stringy stuff coming out of my
stool and like oh
god
yeah don't don't don't eat the horse
pace people
yeah so there's lots of people who are
coming in sick like poison control but
just imagine the world we live in
the vaccine
free
administered to billions
now fully approved the pfizer is fully
approved by the fda people would rather
chug horse [ __ ] paste yeah than take
this vaccine why because of [ __ ]
like joe [ __ ] rogan who's too much of
a coward to stand up to his own
principles when he gets sick he should
have just sweated it out and been a man
be a [ __ ] alpha sweat it out
no he's beta as [ __ ] he took medicine so
beta take medicine
anyway he also says he took z packs
which is an antibiotic which should
definitely not be taken for covid19
because surprise surprise cover 19 is a
[ __ ] virus
not a bacteria and one of the great
missteps in medicine is
taking an antibiotic
for viruses because all you do
is make the bacteria super resistance to
antibiotics it literally uh
is horrible to do this
and ironically joe rogan
so [ __ ] ironically
uh
had this conversation where he says
vaccines are just ours vaccines can
cause
super
viruses but that's what he's doing with
the z-pack
coming out there's legitimate articles
jamie i'll send this to you now there's
legitimate art because
doctors have been sending me these
things and you know this is neither pro
nor con vaccine i'm not it's con this is
not a judgment statement but
imperfect vaccination can enhance the
transmission of highly virulent
pathogens right so okay now let's
remember that the author of this paper
literally came out and said joe is
misreading
it's disturbing and
and he said it's even worse than that
because people in my profession are now
afraid to research important things
because we're afraid the people like joe
rogan are going to take it out of
context to harm our field okay
but here he is taking zpacks
this is from ab
this is from a doctor in the family yeah
from a doctor in the family very smart
guy very smart he said this is a great
description
uh prescribing antibiotics for viral
infections not only doesn't help it's
actually public health catastrophe
waiting to happen especially as a large
following z-packs are a first-line
antibiotic for a lot of conditions it
has a good safety profile and can treat
things from pneumonia to chlamydia
that being said using it willy-nilly
creates an environment where only
bacteria that are resistant to the drug
continue to grow in our bodies so if
this dude is encouraging million people
to do that it will only increase the
issue with antibiotic resistance we have
in this country conditions that could be
treated with uh zithromycin is that the
z-pad correct for example might need
different antibiotics that are less safe
and have a more nasty side effect
profile so there's joe rogan
thank you joe
yeah joe thank you
it may have been the regeneron it may
have been the z-pack again he puts them
on equal footing
yeah it's like it's obviously the
regeneron dude of course it may have
been the horse paste it may have been
the regeneron
uh and another one that he's named uh
prednisone is a steroid
that specifically is
for people
who are on their deathbed
they give it to covet patients when
they're on the ventilator basically
basically a last-ditch effort to lower
inflammation perfect send all your
friends together in contrast however
medicine appears to increase those risks
when patients lacked evidence of
inflammation
so basically all of the three other ones
other than regeneron are extremely
harmful to promote and yet he puts them
all on the same
footing
what a [ __ ] coward
it just gets me too i mean i know you
mentioned it but the the thing that gets
me the most is you know
i know he's flip-flopped he at times he
said i'm not an anti-vaxx i'm not
anti-vaxx but what he keep has harped on
a lot is the unproven nature of it in a
distrust for pharmaceutical companies
and everything but the regen i mean
regeneron it's a highly experimental
non-fda approved treatment from a
pharmaceutical company also funded by
the same operation warp speed the same
thing that brought us the vaccines it's
like
no different it really is no different
like that yeah cannot take that and then
poo poo the vaccine right but also
here's another thing joe rogan johnson
johnson is a traditional vaccine vaccine
it doesn't use this new uh technology
nra yeah nra it's a traditional vaccine
rna i'm sorry all right so if you have a
problem with that [ __ ] then at least
recommend the johnson johnson or take
that one it's a normal [ __ ] vaccine
like everything else
you know
and once again the vaccine is free let's
switch it's free it is a free vaccine
and by now so many people took it
already and they're fine
so
what's the problem i don't know if you
guys mentioned it but the pfizer was
fda approved
fully fda approved
but no they moved the goal post just the
fight they haven't approved the
one yet yeah so i'm still riding the
edge baby i'm gonna turn again darren is
actually turning out to be like more
effective that's right long run pretty
interesting
because pfizer was like the gold
standard but then moderna was like well
hold on
it's like more effective against delta
and [ __ ]
but anyway
do you see the inconsistency
joe rogan is not a dumb guy i think he
i think he's really just pandering to
his audience i guess
yeah as we've discussed on the show i
mean i was never like a huge fan of his
but i i would occasionally listen to his
podcast he had image interesting guests
and i think that he is a
good conductor of an interviewer um but
yeah over the last year or so it's just
like his descent into just
right-wing
brainworm territory is uh to see
especially recently
it's just been when he moved to texas i
don't know if there's anything to do
with it but he just yeah i mean listen
dude this whole arc over the course of
the pandemic has been disappointing
mm-hmm yeah
yeah so um
basically that's it i think he's a giant
hypocrite well listen i have a surprise
and i think he's a [ __ ]
not and then when he has the opportunity
to be the tough guy and show how strong
his immune system is he bailed after one
[ __ ] day
that's your alpha lord he bailed after
one day of being sick and got that
regeneron [ __ ] yes sir
well
would you be interested in confronting
him about any of this
oh is he on the phone
i may have uh
set up a little uh a little call-in joe
broke okay bring him up yeah i'll
confront i'll say i'll say all this to
his face
there's nothing i won't say to his face
all day michelle rogan this isn't your
show just come on
what's going on man good to see you hi
joe all right so what do you have to say
for yourself i mean clearly hypocritical
clearly
beta as [ __ ]
seth's episode
i'm eating [ __ ] dinner at a fancy
restaurant in napa no social distancing
no masks right on top of each other
doors closed indoors you're talking
about your there's a door shut there's a
glass window i mean maybe there's like a
part of that door open up and you can go
outside i think that's not indoors
or that's not outdoors outdoors there's
no roof over your head right
joe are you talking about your toys
chandelier outdoors
outdoors you see sky that's outdoors you
[ __ ] you can't have a
we cut him out
joe
all right
i just don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about like he's now all of a
sudden an epidemiologist
you know
i saw a comment that said as his nips
have grown his brain has shrunk
that's an interesting
by the way here's a little clip speaking
of joe rogan being a giant hypocrite bo
so like either you're going to be
vaccinated and not get it or you might
get it with delta and you know there's
or you can be unvaccinated and not get
it too
that's that
that's not going to be the case for like
unless you're you're a hermit and never
you know it's eventually going to i've
been exposed to it many times and i
haven't gotten it
so i got back from the road saturday
night i got up in the morning got tested
and turns out i got covered
[Music]
joe rogan friends
hope you have access to regeneron one
day after you get there and if even if
you didn't get it what's the point of
arguing that i didn't get it flexing
that okay good for you
flexing that he's unvaccinated you want
me to get on the phone and family that
just lost someone
like what's the point of saying that you
didn't get it he's flexing that he's
unvaccinated you also got a lot of money
he's regenerating one day let's just
flex everything that's going good for
you who in his audience can get
regeneron in one day after getting sick
zero people maybe
you know
maybe like
five of them that listen five percent
means everything i would even finish
this video that stuff is the most
annoying thing to me because it's so
selfish
such a selfish point of view and it's
like who knows how many people did he
give it to by the time that he was
unaware that he had it and thinking that
he's so mr invincible oh he gave it to
people there's no doubt so
i don't know i don't know what's so hard
to understand
let's see i'm really curious if he
changes his tune now when it goes back
to the podcast
i doubt it though i doubt it
he's like yeah the horse base was really
effective i also got an nad drip and a
vitamin drip and i did that three days
in a row
and so this guy's talking about tens of
thousands of three days in a row we did
that so wait how how long has he been
treating it because i thought it was
like one day yeah let me go back well so
here let me go back on what day did he
post this video he he said he was sick
for one day felt horrible and then the
next day started here prednisone
everything tested
and turns out i got covered so we
immediately threw the kitchen sink out
of all kinds of meds monoclonal
antibodies
ivermectin
zpac
prednisone
everything
and i also got an nad drip and a vitamin
drip and i did that three days in a row
and so
here we are on wednesday
and i feel great i really had one bad
tens of thousand dollars for you joe for
sure right
easy uh yeah most likely i mean
my name is so unaware that what you're
saying is so stupid i know i'm surprised
i'm good
so we're all good right everyone's good
okay and there have been a lot of
speculation about whether or not he was
vaccinated because as far as i know he's
never outright said
about not getting vaccinated i am
getting involved vaccinated in that clip
i agree because i feel like if he was
vaccinated he would for sure be saying
that yeah
right he would be going i got vaccinated
and it broke through he'd be downplaying
no but he admit to not he said i haven't
got it
he says i'm not back he said what about
people that aren't vaccinated who
haven't got it right because oh in that
other class i see what you could kind of
put the two statements together and
understand from that that is not
vaccinated yeah that seems to be there's
more there's definitely more evidence
leading to you to believe that he's not
vaccinated than otherwise he's not
vaccinated yeah i mean he basically said
it in that clip but hey he got over it
in four days so everyone is just a [ __ ]
yeah they're
immune systems are [ __ ] and they're
broke as [ __ ] yeah
don't worry guys this regeneron [ __ ] is
great
and he is in really good health you know
for for a guy his age so like you know
i'm not surprised i'm like it was going
to hit him pretty hard i mean trump
lives on [ __ ] mcdonald's and he got
survived somehow too right well yeah
again that regeneron stuff apparently
works really well joe posted an hour ago
that he's back outside shooting arrows
good for him i think he's supposed to
quarantine still
what is that oh quarantine
he acted negative after like three after
like i don't know whatever that doesn't
matter you can have a false negative
yeah of course i mean that's true
do you think joel wrote gives a [ __ ]
a day sunday i mean he did say that he
uh quarantined from his family which
that's another thing how long he's
supposed to still be quarantined right i
hear what you're saying yeah it's been
four days supposedly but not everybody
has a giant house that they can you know
stay in a separate wing of the house
right exactly if you need anything it's
like most people can't really do that
can't afford to go stay in a hotel or
quarantine like that so he can yeah
monday was better
tuesday felt better than monday good day
i feel good i actually feel pretty
[ __ ] good yeah because you've got
like steroids and stem cells injected to
your neck you probably feel great uh
that's the good news the bad news is we
have to move friday
the friday show in nashville
it's going to move to
sunday october i love this he's back on
the road um yeah how long should i
quarantine after a possible exposure to
kobe stay home for 14 days yeah
this is 14 days and two negative covered
tests but he got one like three days and
one negative coat that go and he's like
i'm back on the road baby but not only
is he back he's letting everyone know he
said that the rescheduled date was in
october to be no no what abe said that
he posted today oh that was out shooting
arrows or whatever well he's is he doing
that at home probably at home he
probably has an archery thing all right
that's fine yeah he's at home
as much as i like slamming him no i
thought you were american he's not doing
stuff
those arrows are straight as his nipples
bro
that man
that guy knows that he teams it up with
his nip
uh he said he got lasers uh installed on
his nipples for accuracy well maybe i
mean
maybe
i'll be optimistic and just hope that
this was like a wake-up call for him and
maybe he'll he'll get better on all this
stuff definitely not
fourth so that would be the new
nashville date my apologies to everyone
obviously there's nothing that i can
control
um really how about they get a vaccine
what do you mean you can't control it
how about taking a [ __ ] vaccine
that's free
fda approved and if you don't like the
new technology you can get the johnson
johnson you [ __ ] lunatic
baby beta as [ __ ] bro
nothing i could have done
it is what it is that is crazy times
we're living in uh but
a wonderful heartfelt thank you to
modern medicine for really out of this
so quickly and easily
my love to all of you thank you bye i
mean i'm glad he said that
really maybe i'm giving him too much
credit i i just he he you are he's
thinking modern medicine
so is he thinking i mean that's accurate
i mean it it's that's why he got over it
so quickly so i mean at least he's like
acknowledging that okay but again not
modern medicine that's accessible to
everyone yeah he not i agreed agreed a
million dollar medicine right now no one
can get it i want to hear him he has no
problem telling his fans they don't need
to vaccinate i want to hear him say i
should have got the vaccine that's what
i want to hear this [ __ ] say
instead of there's nothing i could have
done
yeah yeah that is
gorilla the fact that he said there's
nothing i could have done is a little
a little stupid holy [ __ ] definitely
something you could have done joe
yeah we actually found out um
we got some interesting information
here's a screenshot of the shows he was
at by the way these
here let me show you
here's some tweets about it
worked at the comedy show with joe rogan
last night twelve thousand people
lots of fun
it's in florida so you know they don't
give a [ __ ]
he requires you check your phone so
that's why there was like none inside
the actual event
oh sounds like no pictures inside yeah
smart
kind of a sad super chat from poppy
seeds just lost a friend to covid that
wouldn't get vast he was convinced by
this rhetoric makes it harder to lose
them because you know they could have
been prevented anger on top of grief
rip dwyane sorry sorry about your friend
that does suck
sucks a big one yeah sorry for your loss
rest in peace
that's [ __ ] up
yes indeed you know here we found out
some intel
um
there's some other
medicine that joe rogan's been promoting
oh that's related to uh farm animals oh
maybe this is a little bit more for
example feeling gassy elephant
tranquilizer
might be right for you
this guy
has an education in bro science
sounds sleek oh it's dr toe brogan yeah
dr toe brogan
and uh so that that one's been really
popular
there's also um elk flea powder
for uh toe pain
elk flea powder
give him a good old snort so you're
supposed to snort it wow that sounds
that sounds a little dangerous but
i'm sure to rogan knows what he's doing
okay if you have headaches
then you want to want to take raccoon
laxative
apparently very effective against
headaches and humans
i eat these bad boys like they're candy
on halloween he says
yeah um
that's toe rogan md
check for corn the critter says
um does your back hurt you use a bald
eagle
beak
[Laughter]
and it keeps going if your nose is
broken try cobra viagra they actually
have the special
cobras
they have cobra i didn't immediately
pick up on the the fact that he was
acquiring
like
he keeps the previous animals uh trade
as it goes along that's incredible yes
he's evolving with each other yeah so so
cobra viagra actually is great for
broken nose it says help me help me um
that doesn't seem like an endorsement so
there you have it
joe rogan bringing you all the best
medicines
for every purpose you can dream of
says oh you guys really want to shave my
head
nice shaving we're trying to give you a
lineup okay so you've got you'll know
that lover boy
what do you call it by the way cut to my
shot have you seen one fly i actually
have but it was in the middle of the joe
thing and it was kind of serious
yeah there was one buzzing around there
but
uh
but why are they on you not right here
not on my fruit there was one on my hand
look look there was one on your fruit it
was just it wasn't an appropriate time
to point out i don't see [ __ ] on my
fruit and i haven't i'm sitting right
here
you already watching can see the fruit
you would think that there would be at
least one fly if this building was
infested there'd be at least one [ __ ]
fly on this fruit
where is it
there's no there's oh here it is on this
fruit you hear that
even
a single fly on this fruit no
[Music]
something doesn't add up
guys in the comments at least tell me
like okay they say oh it has to be
rotting or it has to be safe you would
think that you would see one fly
on this fruit
we're sitting maybe
eight feet apart i'm gonna go to the
bathroom
like something doesn't make sense here
right guys
can someone back me up on this
i'll back you up whatever
i'm in the chat you guys are all
corrupted the chat is not backing you up
i will say the garbage was just taken
taken out the big garbage in the alley
how is nobody finding out saying that
the fruit flies come to open
yeah
so okay okay so not one [ __ ] fly
it is suspicious
nobody finds it odd okay
sure
sure
maybe it'll be old by the time the show
ends
see this sam got this razor that looks
like a lightsaber
it does look like a lightsaber pretty
cool
so you guys know drake the lover boy
albums out
yes certified [ __ ] boy
he he's been having his heart in his
head for a while so i guess that's why
and so the guys thought it'd be funny in
honor of drake
to not only buzz my head but to put try
to give me the heart
the dre cart
so i don't know how that's going to go
well we were thinking maybe uh eli
should just do it
me ela
either's always been very hesitant to
cut my hair because i want even to have
a normal haircut
he was not into it
so let's i wanted to talk about his
merch more
more specifically
drake made a collaboration with nike
inspired by his upcoming album certified
lover boy
and he teased these black tea oh there's
a one fruit fly here i just swatted
really yeah i did i did just swap one
just one
it's one tiny fruit fly uh
i'm being honest good you know but
just one
he teased
the shirts blah blah blah here they are
it's the worst [ __ ]
should we start uh shaving your head
while you show these off or do you want
to not shave your head i'm down for
anything
a b do you want to start
it's going to be a disaster i don't know
you guys got any family plans for labor
day or the the holiday
no we got nada but
i don't think it's gonna go like it's
gonna be super messy my hair
i have shaky hands but i can line you up
i'm the hair
on the shirt bro i'm the hairline god
did you know that
people have been complimented
yeah i must say it's true i've always
noticed there's something very
handsome going on up there and i think i
don't know if it's dan or cameron that
pointed it out and i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah
ethan does have that hairline yeah so
it's all i have is the hairline
like i think i want to start going as
the um
hairline king
you should start
you should start dying it like deep
black like how keemstar does to his
beard
deep black
wicky hairline instead of wiki feet oh
actually i would dominate that website
so i'm the hairline king guys
people have expressed how much how great
my hairline is people go i'm so jealous
of your hairline i'm like yeah but it
comes with all this
it's like you can't you don't get just
this you got all of this with it
you know
take take uh take it easy
people are telling me to line you up
all right let me go to the bathroom and
then you can line me up whatever that
means
go ahead
speaking of flies maybe we should take
the food away or
are we committed to that
[Laughter]
somebody uh uh andre nunez said if flies
only go to old fruit then how come
whenever i go
on a picnic fly swarm my fresh fruit
checkmate i'm team ethan all right all
right andres
uh
five dollars please uh put a toe instead
of a heart oh
no oh
i don't know if i could do all that dope
is jessie that's a that's a good
suggestion right there
i want to smell fear not up for it
no i could try it but i mean
maybe i'll start it off and someone else
could no do the heart please just i'm
begging for the love of god please
um
somebody donated fifty dollars earlier
bailey and said uh hi ela i'm a proud
aware of teddy fresh will you be making
uh teddy fresh callers
and then parentheses for pets not asking
for a kink
i do want to do that actually so it
would be pretty cool that's a maybe yes
uh maddie said i was watching an old
podcast from ethan's thin days and i
gotta say i think he's much more
attractive now oh well he's not here to
hear that but um
i'm sure he would be pleased
let me see if i got any others here well
ethan is in the bathroom i sent a photo
of the last time i gave myself a line up
if you want to
show that dan uh we're working with
you give yourself a line up yeah
yourself a lineup
oh that looks fantastic oh i can see why
you're confident
oh my god
what the [ __ ] what happened there
this was a day before i stood up in
lena's sister's wedding oh my god that's
like an evil story maybe yep good times
good times
uh
in the chat said dan you missed it there
was a fly
was there a fly while i was gone
oh oh yes there was there was and ethan
actually was the one to uh point it out
interesting interesting
thank you for letting me know for the
baby update comment i i really have
nothing to say and it's so annoying
um
[Music]
i don't know our insurance is just
waiting until i'm like nine months old
to tell you the gender
but
um
i was just at a i always look at a
routine checkup but like they just
they ask me do you have any questions
and i'm like no and then it's like okay
cool
so that's my update
it's for now
thank you
they have a baby update
uh i'm not hey you know what might be a
attracting flies the meat cake that's
sitting out here that certainly isn't
helping that's definitely
you know
a meat cake at some temperature
somebody just said i am not trying to
start trouble but no one warned ela
about ethan's uh shoe scrape bomb he
left while she left
when she left
you know when you went to the bathroom
earlier pretty much like the moment you
stepped away ethan ripped ass really bad
oh god oh you think she cared great
thinks it's funny when i fart so you can
no he doesn't wait what people are
my mom made a bomb tweet i want to show
you guys
are you tweeting while you're
all waiting on you i did yeah i
responded what the
[ __ ]
oh yeah i was ready i i i did well here
let me show you what happened on twitter
first i saw my mom's great sweet baby
[ __ ]
look at of all the strange places you
can find a chrysalis
apparently that's really a chrysalis so
wow she got butterflies i know she comes
here
pretty good baby i read somewhere that
your mom's the queen of the butterflies
and you're the lord of the
flies okay i'm king of the i'm the
hairline king [ __ ] um get it straight
someone said the interview of owen
wilson they cut up is in assembled on
disney plus you hear it right away i'm
not saying you should make him say more
but
that that that's a great idea
interesting that's a really good idea
it's very i love that idea this is the
first time for me in the marvel universe
hi my name is aquafina and i am in the
movies
i did make a tweet when i was on the
toilet though
you want to see it
i suppose
i suppose
i thought it was good i mean i i
actually
hey twitter world this is yours truly
i eat for the world
um
friends of the show emily baker
said that she was doing a live stream
giving commentary this is a lawyer
yeah
giving commentary on video clips and
youtube cut her [ __ ] off because
apparently there was some copyright
detection and she says i blame triller
i blame trailer she said i speculate
that there's no speculation
and i said [ __ ] driller and [ __ ] ryan
cavanaugh
it's so flipped so yeah i was inspired
by that
from the [ __ ] people know huh look at
that in the bathroom
listen
multitask baby
all right where where are we okay you
want to do this [ __ ] baby come on
all right so we're gonna oh look over
the new merch as a b how did you call it
the
comes in on me what did you say
lines me up
is that some street vernacular
sure yeah
so what so are you just gonna you're
gonna have to buzz like it's just gonna
fall right on your shirt that's what i'm
saying it's gonna be such a mess for uh
you gotta vacuum why are you jacketing
up because i want to ruin my teddy brush
apparently
go ahead
so you're going to buzz at all no i got
to do the sides get it you know nice oh
you're going to like give me a fade and
[ __ ] yeah oh
okay oh my god this is gonna be such a
disaster this is gonna be such a mess
of confidence
we went and bought like a super high-end
razor because
i know that anything but like
uh sheep trimmers will won't do anything
on my hair my hair i freak hair usually
when i try to buzz it at home i break
the shears they literally just tear my
hair out yeah oh my god that did happen
to us yeah it happens all the time
i have like free care dude hairline king
up
how's it cutting it's cutting good yeah
it's not real good i believe in you baby
thank you
so when you say line me up that means
like fade and [ __ ] yeah
okay
do you have experience cutting here nope
don't you shut his hero he showed us
some of his experience if you want to
see
oh for real
where do i see it
okay
is that supposed to be like a he had to
go to a wedding like that
is that an accident or is that supposed
to be like a cool line that was an
accident
i wish we could play some drake
[Music]
anyway let's review the merch
so you got the nike swoosh we like that
here's where it goes wrong
you've seen this shitila yeah this is
official merch
something other than me has got to give
and the craziest part is that certified
lover boy is like right above the ass
like a [ __ ] dam
oh this is on the back of the shirt this
is the back it's the back this is the
front this is the back oh
if it's on the front it's even weirder
it's like pubic hair because it's like
you're leaving a lasting message
like a heartbreaker
wow
okay this one's super interesting i
don't miss let alone miss you let alone
is of course two words
so there's a literal typo on his merch
made by nike
let alone
he's a [ __ ] typo on this nike that
has to just be a mock-up or something
right they'd [ __ ] go to the website
is there a website for these well even
if it's a mock-up you don't [ __ ]
type off yeah
is this available for purchase let's see
if the typo is on it
lots of fumbling behind some attachments
there's some
bit of fumbling i feel bad uh
cutting all your hair i don't know it's
fine i need a haircut anyway i don't
care it does look good today though
actually doesn't it
yeah well so much for that
set lineup
line me up
is this available for purchase online
i'm not seeing it i don't know anywhere
but it is like what they called official
so yeah yeah yeah this is the official
show they announced it it has a typo on
it guys
that's amazing
should have said you love me today
because tomorrow is a new day
yeah i mean this is the worst [ __ ] i've
ever seen in my life yeah
it's horrific
very emo too like
pretty embarrassing to wear this i have
to say
and this placement is just horrible dude
what the hell
how we looking either
you lining me up i don't know yet maybe
you're feeling shaky right now
i'm always shaking you got the shake
hands right now the heart in this place
has it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah unless you want
to do the toe [ __ ] i think we should
just do it then what the [ __ ] you
talking about you gotta cut my hair bro
i know i'm gonna go from the front back
okay
oh [ __ ]
so as amy does this
oh boy
[Laughter]
you're supposed to wash it first so it
doesn't get caught up like this oh my
god
you're literally looking and touching my
hair
you mean you forgot i have chilled
all right
all right so we are buzzing
it's about halfway through
i'm not sure about the fade dude i think
we can give it a flat
i think this
i'm impressed with the clippers though
ow bros
i'm impressed with the av this takes
balls dude in his boss's head he's
impressive about what he's doing
somebody said this is a hate crime
[Laughter]
you about to send me to the
camp bro
i didn't even understand
[Laughter]
at what point does the start look good
people may see your curls
yeah
it's hard for me to do anything else as
this is happening
you ever when your hair is like the
longest like have you ever tried to
straighten it
yeah yeah yeah when i was in uh
i got i don't remember if it was high
school or middle school my mom
chemically straightened my hair oh yeah
and my hair was super long hold on is
there pictures of that
uh oh man i can ask my i i don't have
any
but it looked real bad it looked real
bad
and it wasn't like cool beautiful long
hair it was like [ __ ] up
here and it would it was super long
right
and then it was like
it was just like a really crazy part
like hey arnold kind of hair wow
it really looked like hey arnold hair
let me see pull that up
yeah
yeah it was like this
i swear to god
we gotta see pictures and everyone
everyone was tripping out because like
just looks so freakish
i think i ended up buzzing my
my head after that watch the ear baby
what seriously
this guy
while he's continuing to do that do you
want to take a look at um there is some
more drake wait is there a different
tool yeah you just take it off and you
just do it would you say dan
while he's doing that do you want i can
pull up uh the other drake merch oh yeah
please do yeah yeah
so we want to take a look at this real
quick so either we there's uh
there's some more drake merch yeah
that uh we found kind of on the hard
drive right there yeah we found uh we
found a lost hard drive and uh i wear my
heart on my sleeve but my sleeve shrunk
in the dryer
that's actually pretty deep
you've been testing my patients
didn't know you've got a doctor
is that like a play on patient yeah yeah
she want to write me a letter
but i wouldn't let her
get
it damn his lyrics are pretty deep
actually
[Laughter]
arguing over the wi-fi
i just say why fight
let's have a wife knight
yeah that's a good
yeah that's good write that down why
would he include that note to himself
it's weird how he writes himself notes
yeah and then that kind of makes it
maybe he writes it in the margin then he
forgets and thinks that's just part of
his pass it off to the marketing team
and they're like i put it on
eating sushi while she sued me
you see me order sashimi
but you the one
acting fishy whoa that's a good ass line
yo no say what you want about drake but
he is a great lyricist
you have the keys to my heart
but i changed the locks
got him that one's just straightforward
like boom
change those locks boy
it's all you bro dude you've come so far
oh i have it here she got pulled up i
was a bit of an ass
but it takes two cheeks to make a butt
so that's super deep actually
that's super deep like actually that's a
really good lyric
did you hear that ela no go free look i
was a bit of an ass
but it takes two tweaks to make a buck
that's kind of a great line
[Music]
by the time you found my [ __ ] on your
lawn i was all ready
oh my god we should make that one
that's true though
damn
i showed you my love please respond with
bobs or vagina for janna
true
kanye west please stop coming to my
house i have alerted
that one's just a straight up that's
just like a statement that's not even
like
no that wasn't a verse on the on the new
album
oh and that's it i respect that line
though it's just so straightforward yeah
he's still my heart
[Applause]
[Music]
is this it this is the moment of truth
here we go
can you get a zoom in yeah
your hands are shaking dude
be serious about this i'm trying
he's serious
his hands are like so shaky right now
i don't see anything
the [ __ ] is that
this what is this there's nothing here
[Laughter]
oh wait no i actually kind of see the
outline of it
just shade the complete heart zoom in oh
yeah you want to do like a full fill
try to take a full filled heart oh god
maybe not
you i am olivia
now
look how he's shaking
i have tremor again
you can't help it you do you dad he's
got shaky hands
that's why he was the best suit i know
that you should be in my barber
i didn't know that you had that here
give me that thing i'll do it myself
okay give me the zoom
here we go
oh boy
do we have a mirror if you give me a
mirror i can do it for real
i'm going to turn this thing off
stressful
why you guys give the shaky hand dude
the one that [ __ ] do maya
all right i feel like i'm actually a
good barber here oh thank you okay this
is great
everybody was saying we should call
donna
yeah
get our advice
okay can you guys see
i mean we see your profile yeah that's
fine yeah yeah
this isn't i don't think this is close
uh oh there's a fly on my drink
i mean it's all the way down let's see
if i can bring it up i flew
yeah like i feel like you must use a
a straight razor or something for this
i don't think that this is the right
tool
oh my god
that's pretty good right
hang on
don't do the feel
[Laughter]
it looked good for a minute
oh my god what are you doing dude i'm
doing the hard
somebody had to take the reins with this
segment yeah
ethan's stepping up right now hila when
is rosh hashanah okay it's this sunday
or monday oh really yeah right up look
at that heart i think
you should just shave everything else
and leave that
god i'm a certified lover boy
sorry eli try to prevent this yeah thank
you everyone yeah this is like an actual
barber's
professional buzzer
it's gonna be rough clean up
i'll clean it
oh my god
you want me to get the back or you got
it
um
i can do it
you want me to go to the bathroom
just leave it with the bath it's not
going to take long no i'm
let's see it
yes
[Music]
i mean i used to do this all the time so
yeah
you got it you got it down
this is good
how am i looking back there you go
brush it's hard to tell because there's
hairs all over you at least you guys see
what a nightmare it is for me to shave
my head
like i'm telling you guys you all think
this hair is a game
you all think that this hairline comes
without
oh [ __ ] the back of my head is so [ __ ]
look at on the screen
[Laughter]
yeah let let ab fix it oh you missed it
yeah that's good yeah yeah yeah you're
making it happen no this is good but
then closer to the ear there's another
line
american history climb
i don't know why this always makes me so
uncomfortable
you don't know why yeah
i know why oh god
[Music]
lina too she always whenever i freak out
and start shaving my hair she started
like crying like what are you doing
[Music]
can someone carry the show while i do
this okay
all that hair is going to attract so
many flies
oh yeah true
no
no not true we love a bald king the chat
is saying
ethan you look so hot you think yeah
50 donation from garrett ethan can't
admit he's wrong about the fruit flies
like joe can't admit that the covet shot
is safe the crew is 100
the crew is 100 right
i'm willing to put 50 on that thank you
i admit i'm going with the beard too no
what oh my god
they said the chat's saying not the
fester curse it will lead to a divorce
oh no
nobody ordered pizza
someone said shave the eyebrows too no
no
oh my god
this show will be cancelled if you save
your eyebrows
that's the end
you should leave the stash
yeah just go just go stash leave the
goatee
oh my god it is american history x
american history club got the [ __ ] ed
norton goatee
whose idea was this segment by the way
whose idea was it i want to know not me
i'm literally just giving myself a
[ __ ] haircut yeah the show bro ian
oh this was the end i'm always trying to
get you yeah
yeah i liked his hair that one time the
barber did it looked really good got it
i think he looks fresh
you do looks like walter white
i mean i actually just want to do it
right because i don't have to cut my oh
my god bro did i look like a different
person oh my god
thanks ian
who is this person
this is a new person ian's favorite
person this is somebody new that we
haven't met yet smethan's you are the
danger you're heisenberg
i don't look dangerous
i have to leave blower if you didn't
already get the very fight you know
no he didn't no yeah
i'm thinking about it he was canceling
because i just want to make sure
nice and clean you know
you're a certified lover you should be
going lighter
right here
there's like a big spot right at the top
of his thumb
[Laughter]
here straight all the way down all the
way down
like that yeah i feel like you're
putting way too much pressure okay why
out
[Music]
that's why
i always pressure you got it bro you
don't got hair like this you don't
you're not the hairline king you don't
somebody said they'll donate a hundred
dollars for the shaved eyebrows no he
has money he's good do you think 100
telling you the show will be cancelled
it's
walmart brand gabriel iglesias
[Music]
if somebody donates
to a charity like a cherry drive
for me to shave my eyebrows
i'm
ethan looks like walmart brand gabriel
iglesias
i kind of want to shave my eyebrows
all nathan i think i got everything guys
yeah okay i think you just witnessed a
full
lover boy okay yeah somebody else
donated 50 uh mexican pesos ethan's a
certified chicano now you want me to
clean you up
i don't know how you're going to find
that baby now
he's got he's got a tool for the job you
got to see get over there baby
yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's get this out of the way oh my
god i love that maybe a a leaf blower
you're going to have hair all over the
studio yeah dude that's going to be
so hard to clean yeah
are you sure you're like maybe worried
about the dog
yeah shredder you look too sweet and
innocent for this
all right go for it
i don't know
maybe just sweep this hair out of the
way first because bro that hair oh dude
i don't know let's go back a little bit
then we can separate it
yeah yeah
okay
[Music]
blow me right quick
[Music]
hit my shirt
[Applause]
here hit me hit me with it bro
hello
oh my god
[Laughter]
open your mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
they should have that at the at the
hairdresser
that thing rules
can i get a new chair
oh my god you guys i did not expect this
all to come from a drake merch
[Music]
didn't put that much looks like a heart
right he put a lot less effort into his
album roll up
uh somebody said keep the heart
uh let the heart grow out keep the rest
look at love what's happening
that's terrifying
why what what's happening
stop the madness from that's creepy
don't do it
i hate it you don't eat anything there's
hair and everything though
there is definitely
everything don't see any flies
but i feel like there's
what do you think though i mean i did it
right i mean you did the heart well for
doing it yourself i think you're sort of
freaking out yeah you're certified
it looks spotty though
that's kind of as good as i can get with
that hairline like this
yeah
it's just because the light
well we started as one person and we
ended
as a whole another
how many people can say that
um
ethan looks like the fake michael
jackson from the simpsons
[Laughter]
man that was such an epic iconic episode
one of the best oh they're saying die
the heart that could be cool actually
yeah
yeah you got to do like it's a whole
process isn't it yeah yeah
this was a guy who thought he was
michael jackson
i could paint it
to paint it sorry let's not get into all
that yeah
yeah totally i see it for sure
i'm looking in the bed in the mirror oh
ow
okay i wanted to take you guys tally we
talked about making a shirt to raise
funds on our lawsuit against frank
cavanaugh
this comment
is that i'm mexican ethan looks like all
my uncles i don't know
dude when i'm in mexico people think
they start speaking spanish to me
they really think i'm mexican with your
with your head shave you
i can kind of see it it's weird
i don't know why i could kind of be any
race you know i'm like i'm ambiguous
ambiguous ethnically ambiguous this was
a ruse to blow the flies away hey
oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] fruit or i mean no
flies well we've had a couple okay but
like if this place is so infested
just saying there's none on the fruit
is there a spanish version of ethan you
know what i mean we're looking at it
like the name oh
you know ethan
i
don't know like jose
is
joseph
joseph yeah
so um
i'm not seeing
i'll go by israel that's popular and i'm
jewish
israel oh here's a reddit thread about
it is there a name for ethan in spanish
etan oh that's how you say in hebrew
eitan
is on i-z-a-n
really
it's one according to the spanish
wikipedia is on
it would be ezon or e is on with an
accent over the a
here we go
i'm trying to decode this
i'm sure there's meaning somewhere in
that garrett you don't you don't a
hundred dollars you said sorry ela but
the eyebrows must go they said they said
they weren't gonna do it for a hundred
dollars you just wasted a hundred
dollars my dude i'll do it right
would you put it
in your eyebrow no
i'll do
i think it's cool
where does it go where does it go here
like right at the article
i don't know uh
[Music]
all right i'm gonna skip the eyebrow i
don't wanna get shot you know we have a
meeting at teddy fresh effort after this
yes we do
yes we do yeah uh oh yeah i forgot to
mention that four it's a bunch of
investors actually
nobody invests in today i'm kidding it's
a joke just for the record
all right well hey it's some new me
they'll be all intimidated people will
be looking at me funny
i'll be walking in and just feel like
i think you look intimidating you look
fly as [ __ ] dude
thanks
i mean obviously it's a little patchy on
the head but you don't look bad with the
shaved head you look higher than our
infestation problem
[Laughter]
blood infestation problem exactly
count the flies on my fruit
count them cereal
what an infestation two
okay so kavanaugh so we're going to need
a poll for this so here's what we're
planning elo we want to sell limited
edition
brian cavanaugh lawsuit merch now last
time our ideas were awful
so today we have a new oh yeah well the
last time we talked about having there's
a picture of ryan kissing harvey
weinstein on the head
and
suffice to say some people were not
happy about the idea of us putting that
on a shirt which okay i get of course so
we changed it up
what's so funny about that graphic is
that not every graphic on getty you can
license but that one specifically you
can license
of ryan kissing harvey weinstein i mean
what the [ __ ]
it's so crazy that is crazy i mean
forgive me forgive me i thought it was
funny but you're right let's not put
let's not put harvey weinstein
okay
so we've got new designs and we wanted
you guys to vote on um
on which one
you like the best
so can you make a poll
okay great
um and also add an option for none of
them are perfect too
none of the above yeah none involved so
the idea is that we'll make a limited
edition design signed by everybody
everybody this is crazy we never sign
[ __ ]
so we're all gonna sign this shirt we'll
sell it for like 75 bucks because it's
it's a collectible
and to raise money for the lawsuit let's
be honest i don't need money for the
lawsuit it's really just merch and also
to piss ryan off
because he's trying to waste my money so
if we can raise a bunch of money just to
say [ __ ] you to him that'll be great
it's like okay dude you know
douche
all right so here's the shirts so you
guys vote remember limited edition so
notorious kav this is the parody of the
notorious pig ready to die this is the
what what
oh zoom in
the notorious k av
cav cav
ready to lie under oath
as you know big ready to die
now the context of this i have to give
context so you know
uh the judge said he lied under oath
about falsifying
the document claiming
that his ex-president
uh
was accused of sexual harassment so it's
a reference to that
also i just want to say for the record
that these are not being made yet if you
guys like it it may be subject to
further vetting
promote lawyers
ready to lie under oath
this is ryan cavanaugh
first amendment for me
not for the
triller vs client 2021
commemorative shirt
scam
of course a parody of dan
and the previous one is of tyler that
creator
yeah this was igor yeah
it didn't really play on the words
though right it said what was the first
version it said uh
yeah it said ponzi
but with you know we had to add like oh
well later retracted it was too much
information a bit so we didn't we didn't
fit we took out the ponzi gotcha
but this one is scam
accused of ponzi by ex-partner with the
astrix accusation later retracted
so that one's all good
this one i like a lot
moving on this is of course uh taylor
swift's uh reputation
kavanaugh capcab
hollywood financer arrested for dui
again
light under oath sued by babysitter
forged documents light under oath so
that's our boy cav cav
brother taylor swift the swifties
oh and matter of law 2 executive
producer ryan kavanagh
so which do you guys like the best or
should we keep working
one
two
three four options is this this
this is the same option right yeah
no those are two separate things oh it
looks like part of this i feel like it
needs his face on it
you know
[Music]
well okay as a concept so we have four
different uh one yeah
okay so
yeah they got it already all right let's
see i i personally like
i'm not going to vote yeah don't say i
see the results
that's it so
so the voting is coming in
the commemorative kavanaugh verse
ethan klein lawsuits for fair use and
first amendment free speech
signed by the whole gang
it's still coming in
let's give it another minute for the
lawsuit and to stick it to this man
who's been arrested not once but twice
for dui
that's all that's
too too many dui's if you ask me
um
still populating are we crashing the
website again
it took me a second to get on to it so i
might want to just give it another
minute give it a couple minutes there's
not that many votes in here
[Music]
what do you guys think i think that
consensus was kind of like 75 bucks for
signature from all of us was the limit
that seemed like a fair price to
everyone
yeah yeah like maybe if it's india
signed by everybody i think so that's it
because that means you're not gonna make
a lot of them i think we should make
them to order mm-hmm
so it'll be like a pre-sale of whatever
two-week or whatever like of probably
four four weeks what do you think
because we'll probably just buy some
blanks and then print it on it and sign
them
so if a thousand people buy we gonna
sign a thousand shirts that's what i i
don't think so i think you'd have to
limit it
oh
i think we should sign a thousand really
am i getting a cut of the revenue
wait how much money is that let me let
me crunch the numbers and see like what
actually i'm dealing with right 75 times
a thousand
75 000 right
yeah
that doesn't even come close to covering
my legal
yeah and that's going to be a lot of
work to sign it down that's a lot of
signatures
jesus yeah wet my beak a little bit
making it fine if i gotta wet his beak
i'm not even gonna i'm gonna be in the
hole after this [ __ ]
so the overwhelming you want to throw
this pull up the overwhelming winner
is
by unanimous decision
done by the one star app trailer given
one star by honest review
scam
[Applause]
accused of ponzi scheme by ex-partner
accusation leader retracted
that's clean boy that is a clean one
awesome yeah i love this one
so i think what we'll do is put it on a
white shirt we'll all sign it
500 per
i'm just kidding
damn okay well we'll figure it out we'll
start working on that that's exciting
love
that thank you for the feedback and yeah
we will definitely not include the one
of him kissing harvey weinstein lovingly
on the head as if to say my dear friend
who i love and respect i will always be
there for you uh maybe i should remember
that would have been funny to write on
it
uh the the one with harvey yeah because
my dear friend i love and respect you
and i will never
leave you
ryan to harvey weinstein we were told by
many people that
no variation of that would be funny
no sir all right you guys been building
up this next clip for so long this
pasture covering we gotta wrap it up
okay so this is a wonderful conclusion
this is the one that dan has been
this is actually an ian fine credit to
ian for for digging this up i don't know
how he came across this uh someone on
the discord uh
sent oh well shout out to the discord
user only 400 um
likes on twitter you guys all urge me
not to watch it it's so good so i have
not seen this
i've seen the dis it says pastor dan
burgoyney
burguini
covers his hand and talks [ __ ] to make a
point about sin
sounds good man sounds [ __ ] good what
god
equates as sin
in the bible
he equates poop
is that true
filth
in the bible
no this is not a brownie
no this is not snickers bar
good i own tubal mastiffs in my life
this is great thing
do you know how god sees now listen this
is important psalm 141 verse 2
may my prayer be set before you like
what
like incense
may the lifting of my hands be like the
evening sacrifices
your sin god says has hidden my face
from you so that i will not hear so when
you come in and you're saying god the
gods of my life compete with who you are
but i'm declaring that i belong to you
god says this is what i see
i see
comes up like incense before me
and what's going on in your soul i can
see in ways nobody else can see
oh and so you know what you say oh god
created me a clean is he gonna keep
doing the sermon like with dog [ __ ] on
his hand like how much for longer does
this go on
cast me not from thy presence and take
not thy holy spirit from me and you got
chunks coming off of your thumb and god
is saying what do you want do you want
me or do you want you
do you want your ways or do you want my
ways because you can't have what you're
getting the way you think you want it
unless you're gonna make me the absolute
priority of your life
oh my god
so this is was he saying that that's
real human poop
dude like damn
do you hear the gasp of the audience
i don't think anyone was listening to
him and i don't think he was even i
think he was regretting it
i don't know man i guess a dumb ass
colt
all right
oh
lord
disgusting
somebody in the chat said check for corn
you know it's like uh
is your message that powerful if you
need to resort to that kind of theater
you know
that was disgusting
i just
if you need to rub dog [ __ ] on your body
to get your point across i think that
your point doesn't have enough merit to
stand on its own
i don't even know what kind of point he
was trying to make there's a fly here
show me
oh the little the little thingy you know
why isn't it attracted to the fruit i
don't know but why is it here
probably because the garbage is full of
trash it stinks like doo-doo
it's the blood of god no maybe it's the
dog the doberman [ __ ] the damn
all right someone on the reddit just
posted something saying that i was
dumping all the hair on ela and i
apologize
re-watching it
i don't know at least from the camera
angle it didn't look like i was scooping
and like
i don't think so
okay okay
well
i see two hairs
that i can take care of that's okay
that's about it guys
happy friday
long weekend too labor day baby it's
friday baby
three day long weekend [ __ ] yeah baby
[ __ ]
you guys excited
i'm um
we got something to do i'm working on
the weekend so no oh really you guys
have worked tomorrow yeah
it's just me and dan sucks to be you
what the [ __ ] what are you guys doing uh
we're launching a new show for you on
our podcast channel and there's a lot to
do it's called baby oh you guys are
working on the new show tomorrow i mean
they're clearing out somebody's got
oh
yeah we're actually we are uh this will
give a little
okay so there's been a lot of
speculation on the subreddit about the
uh new show and
a lot of people seem to be under the
impression that it is like kind of a
continuation or the new version of oh no
hold up hold up don't give anything away
oh well you this was going to give it
away man
[Laughter]
never mind
mystery
what were you going to say
unauthorized statement
we're tearing down the frenemy set yeah
yeah yeah you can say that you can say
that yeah yeah well that gives
the thing is everybody thought it was
going to be a new like frenemies and i'm
saying we're tearing down the friends
well that kind of well we're just
shooting in the studio which was always
my dream if you remember or not right
that is true i wanted to we're tearing
it down we're bringing it to the studio
we're rejiggering some things for yeah
trisha did not want to come to the
office with peace and love the new host
no problem he's happy to come to the
office
excited even but i will say i saw some
people saying it's airing this sunday
it's airing next sunday is going to be
the first step yeah we'll be shooting it
next week and it will uh yeah it'll be
up should we take some more guests
people guessed basically everything
wrong nope
you think three shrouded a mystery trout
in a mystery people keep getting so mad
at me
do i tell who it is
it is
the
um pope it's the pope pope
guy it's francis the baby we're waiting
for the baby to visit a baby yeah
the new host of frenemies is
well you know because i want to
clickbait that title the new host of
frenemies is the first app and then
everyone goes crazy
let's discuss that oh come on everyone's
nodding i got people nodding yes you
guys nodding yes i got dan and ela
hating in my ear
then we already did that we literally
did right yeah okay and zach's giving me
the thumb up just the new new host
exactly and the new host of frenemies is
the dates on the episode dan they'll
know it's not the you know
is here here's the new the new host of
family friendlies is
karen from tick tock
the sex was the best stepper thank you
so much my friends
you see when you take the risks there's
plenty of reward
i'll tell you it was really good
alexa volume up
[Music]
thank you so much the new host oh there
she is everybody
karen
from tick tock she has so much to say
and we love her
i'm smoking heart
like kardashian
kim you look absolutely mega in that
picture on the los angeles magazines
dude we needed to call him kardashian we
nailed it what a great selfie with that
dog that is
wonderful i hope you like my outfit
i want to be as sexy as you my darling
how about if i do a sex tape
i might do it oh my god
karen i'm gonna come we love it it's a
family
show i'd like to pose and play boy do
not come i'm trying so hard not to come
coming
let's swallow she's hearing music in her
head humpaging the last walls with you
i
forgive me but um what are they called
you get your pass your hall pass is that
what it's called
that's my hall pass
she's irresistible
i don't have a hall pass right no i've
never asked you for a hall pass no today
i asked so he's my favorite person on
tick tock i think
there's one more you want to watch it or
you got to wrap it up
we're doing it direct directly let's
wrap it up
one more
karen manifesting to show us out
until the weekend baby
i'm crazy i want him in the worst way
what am i going to do
i'll just manifest it might take me a
while
i'm crazy that's the woman who knows
what she wants
all right guys
happy happy weekend thank you all so
much
please subbie we need sub or we need
subscribers
subscribe to the channel the 40 of you
out there i started asking people to
subscribe
the haters smash that subscribe button
smash that like button
five percent means everything
thank you everyone have a great weekend
and we'll see you next week
[Music]
sleep shredder would stop barking off
raiders at the suite we'll do the real
raw ritual with more an e.t share relax
with the ring just see how low jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always doing right
you